[Laughter]
hey you guys getting run over by a train
well that's what i said because every
time i put that little thing on it's
like i was like wait here it goes
getting rid of my truck yeah [ __ ] 13
o'clock comes runs you right the [ __ ]
over that's
[Laughter]
oh you've got your ocp shirt on
yeah it's a new ocp shirt yeah that came
out
that came out nice actually yeah uh
bees nest yeah murder hornets he's in
there yeah yeah uh it shipped out today
yeah the they came in finally yeah we'll
see everybody else too who ordered who
ordered because next dimension media was
like the other person that ordered
shirts yeah they got it was supposed to
go out yesterday but the mailman came
earlier than i anticipated yeah so uh so
i didn't get the [ __ ] out on the porch
in time
after 12 afternoon no it was more like
10. it was more like 10 or 11 yeah and i
was just like well [ __ ] i just look well
because i didn't want to leave the stuff
out on the porch like for a long time
even though i just you know no one would
steal it it's not like anybody really
walks around our neighborhood and our
driveway is super long and you can't
really see our front door and porch that
well from the road anyway
so maybe i'm just being paranoid but
you know but they took it today so
people steal [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
it's like you know so i don't want it
out there like longer than i mean you
can what you can do i noticed
is that you can either have them pick up
your [ __ ] like when they come or come
into your house any way to drop your
mail off which is free but if you want
them to come at a specific time then
they will but you have to pay an extra
25 dollars
yeah no we're not gonna do that i mean
it would be worth it if it was something
really expensive that you didn't want
stolen or if it was a bunch of stuff
that you really thought somebody was
gonna make off with then i could see
like paying the extra expense but other
than that it's just kind of like but i
was just kind of like because i never
actually noticed like when the mail came
i always thought it was more like two or
three in the afternoon but i guess it's
more like 10 or 11 in the morning
it depends
it depends that's true but it's yeah
i've never really noticed well it's just
weird because it's like sometimes it's
just like putting the garbage out it's
like sometimes we don't put the garbage
out the night before and they're like oh
we got plenty of time like the next
morning to put the garbage out because
sometimes they don't come to like two or
three in the afternoon but then on that
day that we forget to put it out they'll
come at like seven in the [ __ ]
morning you know what i mean i'm like do
you guys have a schedule or no yeah
maybe they do maybe they just do it like
one way and then they like the next week
we're gonna reverse it
yeah and now you know you were first and
now you're like i don't know i don't
know what time they come yeah danny's in
here
danny i'll block you man stop [ __ ]
stop spoiling movies bro
all right i haven't seen it you're all
ready to say it telling the end
kind of [ __ ] is that i didn't even read
it yeah i don't know little school
thought he said it was it was okay i
don't really care it was okay zach says
i loved your guys fatal attraction video
this morning uh by the way i have so
much to say about that movie yeah so did
we clearly i think that went on for like
45 minutes i hadn't seen it in such a
long time but it was like kind of fun to
revisit it makes me want to watch more
kind of
late 80s and early 90s thrillers
erotic thrillers
not that shitty one with madonna though
there was nothing erotic about that this
is what they took call it well no yeah
that's what i'm saying i'm not saying
that it was necessarily it was it's not
a value judgment i'm just saying that
that's that's what they call it
that's from the
point of view of [ __ ] old boomers
that are long gone
that's just a damn thriller
you know what i mean
a romantic thriller or a not romantic
thrill or a [ __ ] it's like a thriller
that like a stalker thriller that kind
of like takes a it takes a hard
right turn into like horror movie
territory toward the end although we
talked about that on the video how that
wasn't really the original ending
yeah yeah i had to remember that i
remember because i'm pretty sure it was
you zack that like asked us to review it
a while back and i was just kind of like
well it popped up so i was like hey why
not had been wanting to review that for
a while
uh but you know
and then we watched last night we
watched one that we'll probably talk
about on sunday yeah which is uh monkey
shines yeah the george romero movie from
i think it was 88 i want to say 88.89
something like that
yeah we'll talk about that on sunday
what no [ __ ] danny's in there talking
about that it's better than the than the
shame black predator the shame black
better
it was it it was frustrating because
certain elements of it were good and
other elements were really bad it was
just kind of a mishmash of good and bad
it seems like things were shoe horned in
there just because i don't know part of
committee or something it didn't have a
good flow to it
and then they started with the damn
super space alien armor so they can
fight
no no
just not good
um
i just didn't think they should have
taken it in that direction i kind of
liked i kind of liked the idea of the
[ __ ] up dudes from the va because i'd
be one of them that those were the ones
that's what i do for a
living that's what you do that's what i
do you be a [ __ ] up dude
yeah [ __ ] disabled [ __ ] veteran
[ __ ] vfw member and [ __ ] you know
what i mean that's what it's like not
all of us but you know
yeah so that's why you liked vfw so much
yeah although i also really enjoyed vfw
if you haven't seen vfw please see it as
well bfw member but i i never go i never
go those places are
depressing which is why they're ripe for
horror movies that's why that movie was
so good it was kind of depressing in
that but it was awesome
it's an empty bar of old dudes that are
[ __ ] drinking 50 shots because it's
all [ __ ] government
it's government financed [ __ ] uh
watering hole
and those dudes are in there drinking
themselves to death and most of them are
long dead so so it's empty in there
uh now it would all be iraq war veterans
and boy you might get in trouble when
they're hanging out with them dudes
because uh
yeah
they're trying to make side money too
and not all those dudes are [ __ ] on
the right side of the law if you know
what i'm talking about
well i always thought the thing about
like the old school vfw like when my
like my grandfather's in my father's era
it was like you said i think there's
something like kind of depressing about
old guys sitting around like just
reliving their past you know what i mean
yeah and it shifted if i show you guys
pictures of me
in service when i was in the army
service because they did [ __ ] after but
army service i am clearly a child in
those photos
clearly a [ __ ] child and if i can i
go to this biker bar sometimes and these
dudes are [ __ ] wearing [ __ ] on their
sleeves and i'm [ __ ] here you got any
pictures and i'll show them pictures of
my service and they're looking like that
and they're because they can barely
recognize me says yeah i am clearly a
child
you're walking around talking all this
[ __ ] about what [ __ ] we did we were
children yeah [ __ ] what'd you do after
this you know oh and then so you're not
one of us this and i that's what unity
were you in and then they don't want to
answer any specifics i was in the 82nd
as a door gunner there's no helicopter
oh really he goes yeah and he starts
off air cav units
there are no [ __ ] helicopter air cab
units in the 82 it's all paratroopers so
those dudes will [ __ ] talk themselves
into a trap because i can i'll just look
up unit formations for those years and
what units we're in there on the
internet this is the internet now
so they they can't you can't lie anymore
you know
that says what you did you know
you got to copy your dd214 or you
[ __ ] pull out a coin a unicorn and
[ __ ] slap that [ __ ] down and then you
know what that is you know so there's a
lot of [ __ ] stolen valor out there in
the motorcycle scene [ __ ] them fat boys
they're bad boys they just want to hang
out they want to hang out and be fat
they just want to hang out yeah and like
right yeah well it's kind of like a
young [ __ ] like you and i go how
old do you think i am well you're not as
old as me i'm [ __ ] 52 and i said dude
i'm 53.
oh yeah
yeah
are you looking like that why you look
like that
why you really [ __ ] them up why you look
like that huh well because i drink
virgins yeah
[Laughter]
well i kind of feel like well it's kind
of like analogous to
regular ass people that keep like
reliving their high school yeah who are
[ __ ] who [ __ ] al bundy and [ __ ]
talking about that touchdown
like three touchdowns like 30 years ago
what have you done since then yeah
nothing sold shoes i am clearly a child
[Laughter]
yeah that was a long time ago honestly i
don't even remember a lot of stuff that
happened in high school yeah i i have to
say
i don't even remember a lot of it
i did it was a fun time i just i don't
really remember that much of it and i
did a lot a lot of better [ __ ] like when
i wasn't in high school
oh [ __ ] well like way after i was out
yeah
well granters he's probably in the
comments section we had a lot of fun at
that high school i was in two different
high schools though you know one one in
michigan and one in brazil i see i i did
five years of high school
i didn't do four i did five
because uh brazil wouldn't accept the
credits that i earned in [ __ ] in uh
in in the united states they're like
yeah that [ __ ] doesn't count no because
school i went to was ib the school i i
went to in [ __ ] um in in brazil was
basically ib rated international
baccalaureate rated yeah it was an
international high school they're like
wait a minute hold on what you know no
we don't accept social studies
you know you you should have had
chemistry you know where's chemistry or
biology too you know [ __ ] it's that
kind of [ __ ] yeah and really
i may have not have actually graduated
i think they are intriguing what's that
intriguing well they knew that i'd moved
yeah okay
so like man he's been here five years
there's nothing wrong with him yeah you
graduated yeah you're fine you're smart
you're right yeah
yeah because i think
i think i was a like a one or two
credits short but what are they going to
do make you pay for another [ __ ]
year just for like because like
two points yeah
yeah they're just probably like [ __ ]
yeah you're like yeah it's good
because [ __ ] man like one or two credits
it's like look i'll just take [ __ ]
home back or something yeah some crap
uh but i had been to that see i went to
that school twice
i was in it for
um
my freshman year
and then i
and then i went to uh michigan
and i did
michigan i think two years
and then i went back
to brazil and did another two years
that's five years
yeah
so you know
just how it went
[ __ ] man yeah well
i think that's how it went
it's been one year
it was a long time two years yeah
something like that
fourth down said the fatal attraction
video made me remember movies like
jagged edge and the morning after i saw
a movie on netflix today called he never
died with henry rollins ooh i really
liked that movie actually i saw it a
while back i was actually thinking about
reviewing jagged edge because i just saw
it on one of our streaming services not
too long ago i put it in the poll but i
think it didn't win eventually we'll get
around to it i think
uh fourth throw down also says i have no
desire to relive my high school days
yeah me either like i said it wasn't it
was fun i had a good time
um
but i mean it was a lot more fun than
junior high that was for sure that sucks
but high school was pretty fun and i
made a lot of really good friends and
you know it was just it was a fun time
generally but
yeah it's like i don't why would you
want to go back there and do that kind
of grab i think that was fun high school
was the worst it was fun for me because
i was went to a good high school and i
well yeah i didn't
yeah and i didn't have any
responsibilities so i didn't have to
make money
and uh
money had not [ __ ] entered the dating
scene yet so just everything was just
how popular they were how popular you
were what you look like and if you could
talk your way up some chick's skirt you
know what i mean and i was good at that
back then now when money became a factor
you leave high school all of a sudden
you're you're now at the bottom of the
barrel because now you're competing
against guys in their 20s 30s and 40s
and they got all the [ __ ] money
well i kind of feel like in the bottom
of the dating pool in some places even
in high school you kind of are because a
lot of girls like older guys like
college age
they weren't around in the schools i was
in so it didn't matter
yeah oh yeah maybe that was my thing
where i was yeah they weren't around
physically so they just weren't there
well i mean they were kind of around
where i was because it was kind of a lot
of colleges around and there was like
parties and stuff so like people you
would meet like older not in trenton and
in brazil it didn't matter because we
were old enough to go to night clubs
yeah so yeah that's like a different
cultural thing right and uh
and we had money everybody who went to
that school in brazil [ __ ] had money
you know like they were all
the children of politicians at oligarchs
which was kind of like going with [ __ ]
kind of like real rich
arab level wealth giant mansions and
[ __ ]
hanging out with the sons of the
presidents of their presidents and
[ __ ] hanging out with [ __ ] the
dude who would have been king of brazil
had its state of monarchy that kind of
[ __ ]
i remember him his name was louise he
sat right next to me and he was just
kind of a [ __ ]
greasy-haired little teenage kid who
would wear a big old [ __ ] insulated
hand grenade type [ __ ] jacket in the
middle of the [ __ ] summer
it's like that this weird kid and he
would have been he would have been a
king of brazil
in a jacket like that huh yeah remember
hand grenade looking jackets yeah
quilted yeah i know what you're talking
about yeah he had one of those it's like
blue he'd wear that shirt was he just
one of those people that's always cold
no he was like
or did he just think he looks cool like
that
he was just or did you constantly
walking around like he was ashamed or
something looking over his shoulder
kind of like um
real uh
self-conscious
like he was trying to hide
i gotcha he's one of those
real shy
zack says wish me luck y'all i'm going
out for my first cinematography job and
i barely slept last night or ate today
so my body is cashing catching cashing
it's energy debt
good luck
you'll you'll do it you'll kill it
for what it'll be awesome it'll be
awesome
i don't know i'll come find out what
he's saying i'm asking him i'm asking
you
john goris i did lots of things as a
team that probably should have killed me
my guardian angel had its work cut out
yeah i kind of feel like a lot of
teenagers did i didn't really do that
much bad like i said
i don't know i didn't really start being
like a [ __ ] hellie in itself brad
jones says he hadn't been here in a few
months he missed he missed us we missed
you
too we're glad you're back
yeah
john goris also said high school was
basically prison and mine was pretty
chill compared to what some had to deal
with
yeah i mean ours i went to
sea breeze in daytona beach which is
which was literally across the street
from the atlantic ocean
so it was very chill i mean basically
you had 50 minutes for lunch like kids
would come in like bathing suits under
their clothes and like lunch hour
everyone would just go across a1a and go
over there and lay on the beach and get
a tan for 50 minutes and then like run
back over the school
i went to high school at [ __ ] trenton
trenton high in trenton michigan with
granthars steve rouse and marilyn rice
cup who was [ __ ] started [ __ ]
24. she was my girlfriend
it's uh she was in that she's now a
comedian still
and then went there and then i went to a
place in brazil called escola graduated
if you were to see it
it looks like something out of movies
because it was
how should i play your video if you want
to see it looks like [ __ ] paradise
yeah it doesn't look like a school
it looks more like an amusement park
yeah that's what it looks like you ever
seen it
i think you showed me a picture yeah it
wasn't going to be i don't really
remember what it looked like yeah
they're cool
it was fun
it had all grades in the same school but
they kept you divided
you know what i mean like it went from
kindergarten all the way up to [ __ ]
12th grade that's kind of what schools
used to be like here like a very long
time ago
yeah they were in different pods you
were all spaced out they kept you
separate
but then it it had security and [ __ ] and
walls around it big tall walls
casatino wire
and a fleet of buses and it was all kind
of unmarked real low
profile
don't want anybody getting made for
ransom yeah yeah
because that happened a lot yeah and
they were [ __ ] mostly the children of
billionaires
and i was in there
first time i was there i was independent
of
my i was a dependent of my mother who
worked for the state department and she
worked at the consulate there
and then while she was there she met an
american guy from michigan
who uh
worked for a dental manufacturing
company called ker cybron division
they started dating
she left the service
and married the guy well he ended up
buying that company so they they moved
back to brazil they were there 12 years
but once i graduated from high school i
[ __ ] split went into the army so they
were down there for 12 years i go visit
them all the time
that's how i got in there
thank you mark
i like your little
little fox slash katie
zack says uh
ask answering your question from yeah
thank you very much all this damn money
see let me let me see some m flash bob
zack says not a company it's for a local
indie mockumentary thing it's a pair
it's a parody of ghost hunting shows so
you guys might like it that that does
sound super fun actually yeah uh tammy
says jenny i watched all about evil last
night really enjoyed it wasn't that fun
i really did like that movie a lot that
was the last one that i reviewed it was
on shutter so yeah watch it it was from
2010 but it but it's kind of like been
it kind of went away for a long time
because it came out 2010 and then
you couldn't really get hold of it until
they just like re-released it recently
um camp guy says whoops why is my thing
okay i never had [ __ ] for money in high
school or college yeah me neither uh my
parents were cheap as hell i had to
depend on my meal card to eat covered
every meal except sunny days separate
uga yeah honestly i
um
went to essentially a trade school and i
got a grant so i was kind of well my
grandfather paid for my first
semester or my first two semesters
and then uh i was doing graphic design
so he's like well i'm not paying for it
anymore because he wanted me to do
something more practical
um so then i applied for a grant and i
got a grant but i mean luckily like the
college wasn't all that expensive and i
could still live at home like what was
going on so i didn't really have like
any student debt i didn't come from my
money either uh my mother married into
it later after she
divorced my father but they got divorced
when i was a little kid you know that
[ __ ] didn't work out between them
but my mom when she was young she was a
real bombshell so
she married upward
you know
i don't know if i've ever showed a
picture of my mom looked like yeah lots
of times meredith baxter birdie kind of
pornified oh my god i remember her yeah
that's what she looked like yeah wasn't
she that she was the mom on family ties
family ties right the one with the one
with exactly yeah yeah she made it why
do i remember she'd make cassandra
peterson look flat
oh i don't know about that no no
speaking of cassandra peterson she was
in all about evil the movie i was just
talking about yeah
like it was actually like quite funny
danny rowling said a back-to-back review
slash discussion on the films the
shining the original shining and dr
sleep would make for a good show
ooh maybe we should do that
i mean we talked so much about the
shining and dr sleep but still i mean
i still to this day like will watch
videos about the shining i never get
tired of it i never get tired of like
reading about crazy theories but i don't
even give a [ __ ] if the theories are
crazy it's just i don't know it's just
like really entertaining like watching
people like come up with different stuff
about it i don't know i never get sick
of it
um let's see they're talking about henry
rollins
uh
rollins used to be so muscle-bound then
he went all skinny what happened i
haven't seen him lately
henry rollins he wouldn't muscle down i
think the last yeah he was i think the
last he was slightly jacked but that's
not muscle bound that's a big difference
i think the last time i saw him i saw
him and he never died he was in um what
the [ __ ] was that other movie
uh
what was that movie that was based on
that david wong novel god damn it
about the soy sauce like the drug and it
was all like surreal and stuff he was in
that too wasn't he that was a weird ass
movie henry henry rollins
and um glenn danzig
they were musicians you know so they
have to go on tour for a living
and it's real hard to stay on the sauce
and [ __ ] be able to work get the
maintain a routine and that diet with
that lifestyle
so
they can get to a certain size before
some show and a photo shoot maybe do a
state kind of like that for part of a
tour
but they tend not to be able to maintain
that physique uh especially back in
those days
because they didn't really have the
technology they didn't exactly know what
they were doing
they didn't know about how to come off
of a cycle they didn't know anything
about hcg or using clomid to
keep natural testosterone running they
would just take some steroids and go
work out
and then when they'd run out of steroids
they'd just go about their business and
they'd lose all that that they gained
over time because you can't do that
you can't do that
[ __ ]
your testosterone levels won't be right
for up to maybe like a couple of years
if you just do a bunch of steroids and
then come off
and during that [ __ ] 18 months you'll
just slowly kind of shrink down two
years later you're just you just can't
maintain it because you're not producing
normal amounts of testosterone way low
because they're suppressive is
testosterone suppressive
but now they know about all that so they
know how to come off of a cycle and
maintain what they've earned you know
camp guys said we watch the shining
about once a year or more yeah we
probably do too matter of fact we just
watched it what like a couple weeks ago
didn't we which one the shining yeah
yeah we watched it just probably like
three weeks ago or a month ago or
something like that for whatever reason
we were just like center we didn't have
anything particular watch i was like
let's use the shining again
i've seen that movie probably like a
hundred [ __ ] times yeah
uh zach anderson says hey gang hey there
what's up uh yeah murder hornet said he
wasn't big i'm bigger than rollins yeah
uh john smith said henry wans was big
for the punk scene which had a large
amount of heroin and speed tends to make
you a little skinny i think that's why i
think he has like a big neck so maybe
that's kind of why i was always just
kind of like he has just a big thick
neck
i don't know i don't i don't really
think about it to be honest with you
it's like i think that guys like obsess
over that stuff more than women do we
don't obsess over we just notice it
yeah well that's
you know maybe they notice it more yeah
dude well
it's just instinct in us that
[ __ ] he's big man don't wanna
[ __ ] with that guy that kind of [ __ ]
um
glenn danzig was not as big as people
think he was go back and look at
photographs of it first of all we're
about the same height me and glenn
i'm 5'6 that's probably how tall he is
although i've heard some people say he's
more like five four i don't believe so i
think he's probably well that's more
like my height yeah i think he's five
foot three yeah i think he's more like
five six
um
but he wasn't that big
um you know i wouldn't think that he's
maybe 190 pounds maybe
you know which
that's i'm about 193 most of the time
um
body fat percentage mine's probably
about
between 17 and 20 it might be eighteen
seventeen percent
at fifteen you start looking real good
at five you just can't maintain it ten
you look shredded you know
but if you start getting in a sub ten
percent
body fat
you can't maintain it naturally
not even with a pretty strict diet you
got to have a bunch of [ __ ]
drying compounds and [ __ ] steroids
slimming type steroids to keep that look
that's why animals look like that they
they're making testosterone that kind of
[ __ ] holds them in that shape it's
not a human testosterone that can really
do that not naturally
so you're supplementing they call it
supplements
supplements
arnold all the time and his little thing
well sometimes you know we have to take
supplements it means steroids okay
steroids
so that's so that's like the politically
correct yeah they're just trying to like
they're just trying i'm not doing
anything illegal
supplements we almost have to supplement
you they're vitamins you're
supplementing your diet that's what they
call it supplementing
i mean see supplement that is such a
vague yeah you're adding things yeah
that just means you're added it could be
anything yeah i'm supplementing my
lifestyle with heroin
you know supplements that could makes
complete and total sense yeah
[Laughter]
in case of guys like arnie and sylvester
stallone they were supplemented with
testosterone injectable wind straw
injectable deanna ball
deca derablin
the main ones they didn't take a whole
lot by today's standards but they lifted
a lot though but back in those days
there was a stigma so they would just
say we're supplementing supplementing
your diet
because uh in those days and still to
this day people think well oh [ __ ] you
just take steroids you get big
there's a lot more to it than that you
have to lift weight
you know
it just the steroids are just allowing
your body to heal up a lot faster so you
can lift more
and it will increase
it will increase your size over what
your genetic potential was but as soon
as you come off of them it'll you'll
come back down
it's fun getting big not fun getting
small so you don't want to get big
really you get real big those guys die
your heart's just not built to be that
big
it's dumb you know this obsess this
obsession with size and mass it went too
far even arnie was saying you guys are
getting too big man you guys look ugly
you know it's about symmetry looking
good
you know
olympia was a glorified beauty contest
there's no scores it's just judging
it's like mr america you know that's all
it is
john gore said i always liked glenn
danzig as a rock star he's an
unapologetic [ __ ] yeah no virtue
signaling at all well i think he has
kind of the same issue that steven
seagal has maybe not to that degree not
to that degree but he just like takes
himself way too serious the difference
is is that
danzig can deliver
he delivers yeah that's that's a that's
a big difference i mean if you actually
have talent yeah you can get away with a
lot more [ __ ] hurry than somebody
that doesn't really have talent yeah so
it doesn't have much segal can't really
deliver well especially not now
he could put on a good show but he just
was such an [ __ ] everybody turned
against him and
he was not who he said he was
you know he didn't come out says look
i'm an actor yeah i do do these martial
arts but i can't be everybody's ass i'm
just you know i'm an actor see can you
imagine like if he had done that how
much like we wouldn't even be having
this discussion right now like everybody
would actually like like the dude like
man that dude's all right yeah but no
it's like they have to constantly like
no i'm the most awesome thing ever and i
can do that and i was i learned
i was a navy seal and i was taught by
like [ __ ] magic ninjas and all that
they were shut up it's like just be
normal god damn it i think what happened
i think what was happening is he was
hearing other dudes [ __ ] uh lie like
the guy [ __ ] what was his name the
one that was [ __ ] that they made the
damn van damn movie about [ __ ] death
sport no what was it called bloodsport
frank
ducks yeah i think he was listening to
frank ducks i think he believed what
frank ducks was saying or he said i
admire your grift sir yeah i think he no
i think he believed it i think he
believed it he's going like oh [ __ ] i'm
up against that i'm up against that guy
i got to top that i think that's what i
think he believed it my new wig is
falling in my face so he's making up
fake military [ __ ] credentials and
kind of like he said he trained the cia
on how to do [ __ ] it's trained like i
said no they don't need you dude very
very yeah they don't need you
only steven seagal can help us
in this mission it's like tom cruise
follow him up right now
get get the red phone yeah
it's like tom cruise jumping out of the
sky when the [ __ ] cars wreck hey i'm
the only one who knows how to deal with
the car wreck i'm a scientologist
[ __ ]
i'm the only one that can fix this he
gives him his card
put that man on a stretcher
they're like thanks tom we got it yeah
keep that spine straight don't bend the
spine there might be a spinal injury
elevate the legs
loosen that man's belt give him some
circulation they're like thank you we
have also we have also taken junior high
first aid class put your oxygen mask on
it stand back everybody stand the [ __ ]
stand the [ __ ] back this is an emergency
zone
yeah right
let me direct traffic go ahead
go around go around yeah only a
scientologist can do that i mean not
gonna lie if i was driving and i was
like on a on a highway
and there was an accident and tom cruise
was there directing traffic i would be
tempted for a second to maybe just like
run him over
i wouldn't do it because that would be
shitty but i would be tempted i'm not
gonna lie i'm not gonna be too
i'm like what anything against tom
cruise i like tom cruise he's [ __ ]
you pulled it in yourself tom yeah yeah
that's what i would say
he's a douche
he's a douche but he he he could do a
lot of cool [ __ ] i would think about it
i would think about it you know i
wouldn't do it like i said i'm shitty
but that would be shitty thank you again
mark oh now he's got like lots of little
like a little laughter
a little laughing fox laughing with ten
dollars
that's the part i like thank you very
much for the flash bulbs hey that's it
roll them out at us that's right
john smith said i remember eddie murphy
saying in a movie i can kick your ass in
reality i'm calling for security yeah
thank you that's why everybody likes
eddie murphy yeah and nobody likes
steven seagal yeah eddie murphy was i
don't know you can't say that
i can't say that nobody likes steven
seagal i like steven seagal
yeah i'm amused
i'm very amused man he's got a fan base
they got oh i know i've got a fan base
i'm being well i'm i'm engaging in
hyperbole yeah it's happening you know
what i mean because i'm not saying no
one in the world likes i'm sure i'm sure
his mom likes them steven if you're out
there and you're listening don't hold me
responsible for what she says okay he's
gonna stand up he's gonna show up at the
door i heard that uh
i keep waiting i keep waiting for him to
show up at the front door tommy here
that would be so funny and then he
starts speaking to me in embonics
broken ebonics
remember how he just becomes any old
race
he becomes any old race depending on
what how mad he is
he's chinese he's japanese he's black
he's [ __ ] cajun uh he's he's italian
uh he's anything but jewish even though
he's jewish he's jewish yeah i would
like to hear him [ __ ] talk like some
taylor down in the damn [ __ ]
brooklyn yeah yeah we take a little bit
in here putting a little bit
but he'll he'll be any ethnicity other
than his own
yeah that that that speaks to maybe some
issues there's something that he should
work on with the thing yeah yeah
he's from michigan and he's jewish
okay but he never [ __ ] mentions that
i mean yeah
he wants to be a cajun or black or
chinese or japanese
or
italian um he's just a man of a thousand
faces you know
but not not in the cool launching kind
of way
[Laughter]
no
he needs a stunt double to go up the
stairs
and i'm not lying we brought that you
watch the movie and it's just that's not
that's nice and that is we're not
exaggerating yeah i mean we're not
exactly gonna be sitting in a chair and
have a sandbag and it's all goes all the
way up to his shoulder so you can only
see the [ __ ] the from his lips up
the older and the bigger he gets i feel
like the camera's just going to keep
traveling up until it's going to be his
hairline
yeah and then you know what i mean but
here's the [ __ ] maybe i should do
that for this show i'm just going to
have a cardboard cut out of myself just
like this
yeah
although this is the funny and then i'll
just lay over there like eating donuts
or something i did see some recent [ __ ]
that
that steven seagal was doing
on the internet okay he's doing it on
youtube and he was funny he was kind of
making fun of himself a bit oh maybe he
finally learned how to do that i think
he kind of did i think he kind of maybe
he finally i got it i got to do more
research but uh he was he was goofing
around
the most accurate i've ever seen the
thing that here's the sad part about it
the most entertaining steven seagal
material
outside of his first few movies
is his ad is his advertisement for his
energy drink asian experience
that commercial he made for asian
experience
perfectly encapsulates who steven seagal
is and he's funny
it's not
but the thing about it is that i can't
quite tell if he intended no i don't
think he did i don't think he did it is
funny it's funny but he didn't intend
for it to be funny he's funny he thought
he was being sexy yeah i think so i'm
like um i think so i'm gonna
respectfully disagree with that
assistant yes sir
it's like it is really really nice and
in fact it might be the actual
opposite of
whatever that is a big middle-aged guy
in the pool
talking to an
asian model and wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
i can't remember i blocked it out he had
shorts and a [ __ ] like hawaiian shirt
on okay so he was so i didn't have to
like see his chest no no okay and uh
he's got this
i don't know 20 21 year old
asian american model in the bikini and
he's going come on in babe and she's
really giving off some like where's my
paycheck
[Laughter]
come dive into asian experience
you know and she's like
yeah
you can see the ad on youtube
asian experience commercial it's [ __ ]
hilarious
and it
is we're such dicks
had he just gone with that he might have
been able to
to revive his career had his movies just
been like that
well see that's what i mean i think
there's a lot to be said for just being
genuine oh yeah who you are i think the
problem is creep
well yes i mean don't be genuine if
you're a creep i mean get some [ __ ]
help
no he was great man but that was he was
genuinely being a creep in that and i
thought it was [ __ ] hilarious but
that's what i'm saying like if you're a
creep then don't be genuine that that
doesn't apply but i'm just saying that
i think his main problem just like glen
danzig's problem yeah
is that even if you're talented even if
you can do some cool [ __ ] it's like
you're always trying to have to like
make yourself seem like more than you
are and you're always kind of like and
like i said you can't laugh at yourself
you're not like self-deprecating you're
not
honest about your motivations you're not
honest about like what real [ __ ] is and
people don't really like that i mean
that will make people really not
want to like not like you i saw glenn i
saw glenn danzig live uh this must been
in uh 95
94.
he was great [ __ ] fantastic saw him
at venus de milo see the venus tomorrow
axis down in
boston
[ __ ] great show
um
glenn could deliver
it's just i kind of have a feeling that
you know
he had humble beginnings
and he became very popular and very big
very rapidly and i don't really not you
know
i don't know i think it kind of went to
his head
you know
where you're in the limelight all of a
sudden but you don't really have a
history of being in the limelight that's
you know
some people say fame destroys a lot of
people pretty quickly well i can imagine
that it would be pretty weird like even
if you like i get it like i mean if like
for some reason like this would be
awesome if this happened i'm not saying
that but i'm just like just say tomorrow
like somebody decided to option like one
of my books or something like that and
they made a movie and then i got super
famous it's like it would be really
really weird i don't think i would deal
with it all that well because i just
don't really have that kind of like
personality rockstar culture was
different back then it was taken as
seriously like a big deal kind of like
being a movie star so i felt he had to
live up to a certain image to keep the
fans going you know that
you know it was it was you know that
he had to do that instead of just being
who he was and because he did seem to be
putting on an air
yeah you know and um
you could get away with that back in the
[ __ ] days of the [ __ ] 20-second
sound bites and [ __ ] on tv because you
wouldn't get it very much air time they
play your video and they'd give you 20
seconds on there and that's it
and you could put on you could keep up
in there
well you could maintain a mystique
sure but uh
no not in the modern world that was the
same thing with andrew eldridge
the more you know
i was just thinking about him the more
you knew about andrew eldritch the less
you liked him you know as the singer
from i mean he always came across yeah
even when i just saw him and i love
sister mercy okay but even when i just
saw him like interviewed on like 120
minutes or something like that even in
like little
two to five minute chunks he comes
across as
insufferably douchey he is just very
very condescending
you can tell yeah that he obviously
thinks he's 100 million times smarter
than everyone else in the room and he's
just like oh well this and that and the
other thing i'm just like oh my god shut
up i'm gonna punch you in the face right
now it's like why don't you just like
[ __ ] sing and shut the hell up the
rest of the time one of the most
insufferable one is the his uh
his his interview in germany where he
does he spends about an hour in a long
form
conversation with some german
rock music kind of [ __ ] dude and
it's all in subtitles but it's just like
he's just being insufferable and [ __ ]
yeah i know what you're talking about
i've seen german because he speaks
german yeah he's speaking in germany
well he lived in berlin for quite a long
time right he's just and he speaks
pretty much insufferable i mean he makes
he made sting look [ __ ] well grounded
and humble
but i think that that's why i really
enjoyed
uh you know the sister of mercy cover
band that we saw like a few weeks ago
temple of mercy because the guy who was
the lead singer i mean they're a
fantastic band they were like really
really good um but the guy that was the
lead singer even though we talked to him
afterward and he was just like a
delightful like normal person but he
definitely like on the stage he
definitely like gave off that andrew
eldritch
persona like and you could tell that he
was like trying to do
like an andrew eldridge kind of and i
really really appreciate it i'm like oh
my god he's really really bringing it
yeah like he's acting just like andrew
eldritch i just thought it was so funny
and then it was like so funny because
like afterward you talk to him and he's
just like hey what's up yeah we even
talk about music or anything
i invited him he's like thanks you guys
like coming for companies like why don't
you go to ibar after yeah he's like yeah
we might get out i don't think they did
but i think that another girl did yeah
the chick from like this other band of
city and she showed up yeah but uh yeah
i don't think any of the temple mercy
guys did but yeah it was like super fun
um somebody asked us if we did any
larping
no
not that i ever remember
i mean maybe
but i don't think i ever have i don't
not that i'm against it i just never
uh portray down said i'm still hanging
on for the steven seagal range of
fragrances i don't think i want to smell
anything that steven seagal would be
putting out you know what i'm saying
yeah
i
i don't really know
uh mark says just be a tom ross cool
dude cool dude laid back attitude i mean
like i said don't i think it's the risk
well yeah but it's probably you no i'm
not laid back
you're not actually you're not laid back
no i'm [ __ ] i'm kind of i'm late i'm
high strong but yeah tom is very high
tom is very high strong
which is it's funny like maybe a lot of
people like i don't know it's weird
because in some ways you are laid back
but yeah like in some ways like you're
super high strong i have hyper vigilance
yeah
i'm a lot more laid back than you are
yeah
and i've gotten like more so as like
i've gotten older just because i'm just
like i don't care anymore
about anything which is kind of like the
nice weight i have problems falling
asleep i have to have headphones on
noises and [ __ ] to keep in total silence
my mind will just run
well see mine does that 24 7 anyway but
to be honest with you i have like the
same problem but also the opposite
problem because
if i'm
laying awake and there's noise on then
i'll just start thinking about that and
then that'll send me off like whatever
noise is on like if it's a podcast or
whatever and then that'll send me off on
all of these other like tendrils always
and i will never fall asleep oh when i
go off so i have to have quiet when i go
off on one of those little [ __ ]
tendrils like you said that's when i
fall asleep
when i see now i know because it's like
if i like i said if i laid there
listening to a podcast or for example
then um then i would just start thinking
about i'm just like oh that guy's
talking about that and then that would
remind me of something else and that
would remind me something else and then
before i knew it it'd be six o'clock in
the morning no i guess listen to
scientists talk about cosmology [ __ ]
or you know um
uh
[ __ ] quantum physics and physics um
talking about
the probability of [ __ ] like seti you
know and [ __ ] medi
uh which is you know search for
extraterrestrial life type stuff i'll
relax me and i'll start [ __ ] my i'll
start thinking about it something that
they said and i'll start drifting off
that or um
another one that gets me a lot is
mythicism i'm taught you know they're
they're explaining stories of like
samson and john con drawing parallels
between samson and goliath and these are
uh that they're talking about these are
all stories of the nephilim which
demigods and how this [ __ ]
corresponds with
greek mythology
you know that they're uh
what do you call it
the canaanites were just copying what
the greeks were doing it's the same
pantheon just different names
well i'll get off into that [ __ ] and uh
be seeing it all happening and making a
road map of it and going oh yeah yeah
yeah and i'll be appreciating it and
i'll just [ __ ]
drift off into sleep
yeah see that kind of [ __ ] keeps me
awake oh no it does that it makes you
feel calm
and then um
kind of like uh actually i was just
watching this video some guy was talking
about the stephen king dark tower
universe and he drew out a big old flow
chart about how all those books were
connected mm-hmm
you know what i mean there's about 40
books this includes the entire doctors
writes his ass and they're all yeah
nobody could ever accuse stephen king as
slacking that's for sure
and like uh christine and then in a
buick v8 that's all in the same universe
yeah whatever it is which is like the
lesser christine yeah it's all in the
same universe the only thing that he
didn't that he couldn't connect
he could connect the stand into there
and everything because flag and other
stories
the only thing he couldn't connect into
this into the stephen king universe was
um
um
the shining he couldn't he couldn't
connect that in there
it's not mentioned it's not connected
yeah and it couldn't uh like you know it
doesn't reference anything else
and none of the other books reference
the shining
it's just the shining
and the the sequel to the shining
doctor's sleeve dr sleet and then what
was
another one that isn't doesn't seem to
be tied to it because it had straub and
it was the talisman
uh the black house because that was the
sequel to the sequel to the vitality
okay yeah
those seem to be in their own universes
but there's no proof it's just that
there's nothing what about either the
dragon
i didn't see no i don't think that was
mentioned
that was almost kind of like an old
school like fantasy he drew a big flow
chart you can
i thought it looked good
he had a big flow chart in the video
of what year and i love [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that what year it came out and
how they're connected
where they connect at the stories had to
refer to one another
but wasn't you know but the ones i
mentioned weren't in that flow chart
although i think i think they were i
think they i think it's all the same
universe
just there isn't any proof send me a
link to that i'd be interested to see
i'll show it
yeah john gore said i remember listening
to an npr sting interview years ago and
i was like holy [ __ ] his etiquette is
impeccable yeah i mean sting he comes
across as like slightly douchey but he
doesn't come across like anything as
douchey as
seagal or andrew eldridge or even bono
for chrissy i mean sting is like on the
on the douchey scale
he's pretty low down on the douchey
scale
you know what i mean depends on how you
define douche he's just
i wouldn't say he's douchey he's just um
he's clearly figuring some [ __ ] out he's
he's very
he's very elevated he's very
self-elevated that's okay he's um i mean
i don't mind like a little bit of that
he he's he kind of comes across like
he's a uh a [ __ ] um an indian guru or
something that yeah you know and he's
cracked the uh
uh okay
he's the kind of [ __ ] that talks
your wife into some tantric sex
okay sure he's gonna sit in the damn
lotus position and she's going to
[ __ ] climb up and sit on his langham
and that
is going to go and it's going to go up
in her booty all right
and he's just going to stand there you
know like in the lotus position
and you're going to get your woman to
say some alms and then he's gonna
pretend like nothing ever happened
nothing happened then it wasn't sex well
see so i think that's like less him
being douchey and more people more that
people are mad at him for being able to
do that
so it's so it's play it's just it's
playing
yeah kinda but it's it's it's um
i don't think he's really like that
though probably not i think it's a game
probably not i think it's a game
although i'm gonna say right here i
actually quite enjoy well i really like
the police and i quite enjoy sting as an
actor
and i'm not so much talking about or
dune because he was only in that for
like five seconds but
i mean i liked him in the bride
i liked him in brimston and treacle yeah
i liked him in quadrophenia
i just i think he's a good actor
jenny i would like to hear your thoughts
on what have you done to solange i'm
pretty sure
that i did a long-form review of that at
some point might have been a few months
back i'd have to go look but i'm pretty
sure that because i know i just watched
it recently and if i watched it recently
that i probably reviewed it as
well um let's see
danny rowling said just saw a cheesy
decent underground monster style winter
film called the boogens from 1981 oh i
remember that one with the chick from
prom night who gets axed to death just
saying yeah here it is understanding the
dark tower universe in seven minutes oh
it's only seven minutes well you don't
don't play them yeah yeah that's it
understanding the dark tower universe oh
okay
like i said i'm just i i watch [ __ ]
shining videos all day long he's got a
damn
animated look he's got an animated flow
chart
it moves and it shows you where
i'll show you
yeah he does a good job
all right that's cool
see
yeah he's doing that yeah that's some
classy [ __ ]
that's some classy [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
like i said goddamn i'll like sit there
and watch conspiracy theory videos about
the shining all day long so you know
zach says a movie with sting y'all might
like it's called julia and julia it's a
thriller with kathleen turner his first
movie shot on hd video back in the 80s i
think i remember that actually although
i had forgotten that sting was in it now
that you mention it
uh john smith said misery could be
argued is out of universe
but paul sheldon's books are mentioned
in library policeman oh with policemen
oh okay well there you go
i actually um shudder just added a [ __ ]
ton of stephen king adaptations
including misery
and
i kind of want to rewatch it have we
reviewed misery like have we done a
retrospective on it or anything maybe
probably
i kind of feel like we have but then i
was like wait maybe i remember watching
it with you
maybe we did so we probably did a thing
i mean they added cat's eye i know we've
done cat's eye because somebody sent us
that i know we've done salem's lot
i know i and we did need full things
they added that one too and we just did
that one not too long ago but
the best thing about king
besides him being [ __ ] drunk all the
time well he's not not anymore
best thing about him is that
he's
he's coming out of the 1960s
uh paranormal
uh parapsychological research that was
going on in in the universities
so he's not
pulling these ideas out of his ass
like some people would try to do today
or making up his own [ __ ] he's rooting
it and stuff that was actually in
universities of the 60s
so
he's being informed by what he thought
were
you know
credible sources which i believe they
are or i believe that they were i don't
believe they were perfect
but uh you know having seen some of the
[ __ ] that i saw
later on though back in the 60s the
universities the the parapsychology was
onto some stuff
um the military
continuing to [ __ ] with it
i think it has something to do with
quantum physics really i don't think
it's paranormal it's paranormal but i
think it's supernatural it's just some
aspect of physics that we don't fully
understand yet
and
because the stories were rooted in ideas
that he believed in he thought about him
and he made some good stories about it
and what how would that impact reality
if somebody could do this or that
you know this is it's in the shining too
and he's kind of accurately describing
what what
the effects of a [ __ ] paranormal
a person with paranormal abilities or
talents that's a big way to put
what would life be like for them in
extreme cases
and
uh [ __ ] man turned out that [ __ ]
when that poultry guy [ __ ] went down and
some of those out-of-body experiences i
had i at least had kind of a baseline
something to help me
understand what it was that happened to
me so i kind of liked it i liked it for
that it's kind of like the mcu but
grounded in
in paranormal theory you know or
parapsychological theory
i thought it was good and i think that
that's kind of why his stuff
particularly in the 70s and 80s it
resonated with a lot of well it
resonated with a lot of people because i
remember when i was a kid like in the
70s and 80s i mean it was very much in
the zeitgeist like all this kind of like
parapsychological like he had books by
william roll and all that kind of like
in search of and all that kind of stuff
so it was very much kind of like in the
culture at the time so i kind of feel
like there was a lot of that and people
could sort of like release young people
can't imagine it
people believed that to be real even
skeptics a lot of skeptics are like yeah
uh you know you could have it out about
experience that's the projection
something to it
precognitions something to it dreaming
true something to it
[ __ ] um uh
psychokinesis yeah it could be something
to it and there is something to that uh
reports of it go way back thousands of
years it's
even kind of interlaced itself into into
religions especially eastern religions
there's something to it i've seen it
and it was kind of good to have
a background in king or access to king
so when certain things happen i was like
you know
people have been talking about this for
a long time he's bringing it up you know
i'm not crazy you know that's that kind
of [ __ ] you know
i liked it it was good and um
if you're young and you haven't read
those books you should you should read
all those books he was he was fun
fun and could get you to imagine certain
things and
and to consider
certain things
that paranormal isn't as uh
as strange or it's strange but it's
not impossible
you know
had a near-death experience and an
out-of-body experience and
poltergeist which is rspk
1960 style poultry guys it was [ __ ]
wild jenny's seen it not as good as it
was when i was young but
the thing is though is it's not as
[ __ ] life-shattering as the books say
it's not as impressive as the books to
say you see it you go oh okay it's that
you know when i was a kid it freaked me
out bad freaked out lois and red and
[ __ ]
but looking back on it we didn't have a
very good explanation what was happening
so it was just the unknown so it scared
you
you know
you thought it might be demons or ghosts
or something
well if you've ever read any non-fiction
that stephen king has written like his
book like dance macabre he actually
i think i talked about this a little bit
on my scare salon video about uh shining
versus shining was that one of the
things that i love stephen king's
stories
it's just that he has like a really good
handle on what works in horror but
particularly in written horror
and he seems like a big advocate of
ambiguity of like not over explaining
things and stuff like that but i'm
arguing that like every time like they
give him like the reigns of a movie
project then he just forgets everything
he gets what he knows that he knows
about what works in horror some of them
are good some some yeah well
no and i'm not talking about like other
people that have made adaptations of his
stuff because some of those are good i'm
talking about like adaptations that he
was directly involved in
those tend to be
not so great right
but
and i and and it bothers me like to say
that and the thing about it too is that
even though i'm like really into his
older [ __ ] like all of his like old
novels are really good
um i haven't read like a huge amount of
his new ones because like the [ __ ] will
not stop writing man it's like what is
what does he put out like [ __ ] five
books a year i don't know it's a lot so
i've gotten like really behind
but i did read his 2014 book revival
because i'd found it in a secondhand
bookshop and that [ __ ] was fantastic it
was almost kind of like um something
wicked this this way comes a very ray
bradbury and i was just kind of like man
i'm into this that was like one of the
best things that i've like read recently
younger people
they grew up with [ __ ] the mcu maybe
a little bit of this star wars stuff
which i think new star wars sucks but
mcu dc universe
but next generation and boomers too
our version of that would have been the
dark tower or stephen king's universe
and it was all based in parapsychology
it's good good [ __ ]
and it's like well you know
i just liked it
and there's something about the time in
which it came from
you know
but maybe that's just me
mike barrett said only stephen king
books i've read are salem's lot and
carrie those are both really good ones
um
probably my favorite ones the shining is
really good uh pet cemetery is probably
my favorite like the movie adaptation
was okay the stand uh but the book was
really good honestly like a lot of his
old [ __ ] honestly i really like his
short stories i think the man he could
write a [ __ ] short story you're good
yeah a lot of his short stories are
really good uh for the long story i
liked the stand the stand was really
good christine was good
yeah i loved christine yeah uh thinner
was good um
dark half was good
i kind of i liked um
even some of the one i liked even like
bag of bones which was like a ghost
story
i really liked oh all the gunslinger
stuff that i read but i didn't read them
all i think all right cujo that was
awesome that was good too i think only
read three of the gunslinger books they
were really good
gunslingers kind of like happening in an
alternate universe
it's kind of like uh lord of the rings
but involves [ __ ]
clint eastwood basically it's clint
eastwood
in another universe
fighting robots and all kinds of weird
[ __ ] monsters
trying to get to this big tower at the
center of this
center of this other universe that he's
in
it's kind of a fantasy horror adventure
but i really liked a book that he did in
conjunction with peter straub it was
called the talisman that was good yeah
they traded off writing
um you know the
king could do one
chapter and
strava do another i like a lot of peter
schwab stuff good i mean ghost story is
probably my favorite still
but and some of his stuff is a little
um
i did a review of like one of his
novellas called mrs god which i wasn't a
huge fan of well i was i really liked
the beginning of it i just didn't like
like the way it went at the end
but there was that uh rose madder was
good yeah i was gonna say rose matter
was good and uh yeah shawshank
redemption the movie is excellent but
yeah that was actually based on a short
story a lot of it's weird because like a
lot of the really really good
adaptations not all of them obviously
because you know misery carry stuff like
that but
a lot of the really good adaptations of
his work were adaptations of short
stories like stand by me which is an
adaptation of the body which is a short
story and
shawshank redemption which is a short
story which was an amazing movie but i
was going to say dolores claiborne is
really good too dolores claiborne and
honestly i had been wanting to rewatch
that one too because i just saw that one
come up on a streaming service for free
too and i was like oh [ __ ] i need to
like rewatch that one as well i really
really like that one honestly i kind of
feel like
he did a lot of good like um stuff with
supernatural paranormal
stuff
in his earlier days but i think as he
got older
the stuff that i tended to like more of
his was stuff that was more grounded in
reality because i kind of felt like as
he got older it didn't i don't know if
it was just it was if it was him or it
was me or what it was but it's like the
stuff that i read that was from
you know from his later work
i kind of felt like it didn't
like it i wasn't like suspending my
disbelief in the same way that i had
been i kind of feel like the
supernatural stuff that he wrote was
like better
in the old it like in the 70s and the
80s later on i think his better stuff
was more grounded in reality like i said
more like dolores claiborne or something
like that which was like that was like
real people there wasn't any like
supernatural paranormal aspect to it i
don't know but like i said revival kind
of has a supernatural aspect to it and i
really like that zoo
and um i think bethina said that she
really liked revival was that good i
couldn't believe and it's like i hadn't
even because like like i said i kind of
lost track of stephen king a little bit
because the [ __ ] writes so much that
it's like i said i just can't keep up
and there's like a million zillion other
like horror novels i have to read that's
like i don't have time to read them all
so
i just kind of came across like the
hardback for like six dollars like in
some in the second hand book shop
somewhere and i was just kind of like oh
i didn't i'd never even heard of this
one it came out in 2014.
and i wasn't really expecting a lot but
it was really good i mean i really
really liked it a lot like i said very
very
ray bradbury which there's nothing wrong
with that because we all love ray
bradbury
um
dolores claiborne and river wild is
where great films with uh with same
actor both them david stratham or
something like that yeah i mean dolores
claiborne i definitely want to uh watch
again because i really really liked that
movie
um
somebody said mike barrett said it's
just too big of a book for me to read
which one is who knows well i don't know
because i i got behind yeah you guys
have to if you if you guys make a
statement you have to let us know what
it is you're talking about
we talked about a bunch of books so we
don't know which one you're talking
about
yeah he might be talking about probably
talking about the stand
and it stands
yeah it's a door stop that's for sure i
don't know but stan's awesome you don't
want it it is very good you don't want
it to end it is very good but it is very
long
and i know some people don't they're
like jesus christ i don't have time to
like read no it's like a damn soup it's
like a [ __ ]
it's like four stories in one and five
stories in one it's all happening at the
same time and then all the characters
come together in a big climate it's
about the apocalypse a pandemic in the
apocalypse it's [ __ ] badass
they're kind of like on a part of
there's no zombies in it but it's kind
of like the walking dead but without
zombies
just good people and bad people left
those chose by satan and those chose by
god it is literally the apocalypse it's
good
john smith said king's tv version of the
shining is not so good yeah i agree i
did a whole video about it on my other
channel i'm gonna fight i'm gonna fight
for it though
i defend it i know you do i defend i
know you do yeah it's worth getting it's
worth getting just to listen to his
commentary just to hear him say a
hundred different ways i like kubrick as
an artist i just don't like the movie
the television which is fine everybody
has their own opinions you don't have to
like kubrick's movie but come on it's a
million times better the television
versus the tv television version of the
stand is good somebody sent me a a a
re-edited version
a modernized re-edited version that's
been [ __ ] reformatted for modern
televisions and [ __ ] because it was and
it looks really good it's good to watch
so you can't read this i actually quite
like it you can't read the stand you can
you can see the mini series
it was a mini series wasn't it yeah yeah
i think it was three nights at freddy's
yeah i think so you can get it on uh you
can get it on dvd
the new version and it looks pretty sure
they just added that but the book's
still a lot better well that's
99.99 of the time that is always true
and it's a lot more detailed and a bunch
of [ __ ] happens in it that's pretty cool
because they can't cram all of the all
of this all of the nuance and all the
stuff that goes on in a book into a
movie because a book you have
essentially like unlimited time yeah now
the the tv mini series of the shining
i'd like to see
a reformatted version for dvd it's
probably pretty good um
it didn't come across too well on
television
uh some of the special effects looked
kind of corny like the makeup and [ __ ]
but you could probably fix that
and um i mean see but that's one of the
things that i didn't like about it i was
just kind of like well kubrick's version
like the you know and like i said i
talked about this i did a whole video
about this but i was just kind of like
i didn't like that it's like oh let's
make the ghost like look we'll put
monster makeup on them it's like in
kubrick's version they just look like
regular people and i think that was like
creepier
yeah but the the television version is
bait is very faithful to the book right
but like i said very faithful what works
in a book and it works in a movie or two
completely but if you don't want to read
the book and you want to
then that's closer and that's a lot
closer and i will give it that it is
much more faithful to the book and if
you watch that television series it
informs you and explains a lot of the
stuff that you see in kubrick's movie
it just gives you the background of what
it was you're seeing but that's why
kubrick's movie is better and scarier
because it doesn't explain it yeah kinda
it's good
it's just only half the story there's a
bunch of other [ __ ] because a lot of the
story is what the ghosts are doing and
what they're saying in the other
dimension in the other universe
and what the what the uh what the
overlook is doing
and and why it's trying to steal souls
[ __ ] like that it's pretty good but see
the thing about it though is that you
could probably i mean it doesn't make
jack all that sympathetic either
from what i remember
well i'm gonna say and i think that was
a loser i kind of think that that was
like stephen king's main bone of
contention with kubrick's version
and somebody told me like in the um in
the comments of the video that i made
about it said that coop that um stephen
king forgave jack torrance and stanley
kubrick didn't and i think that's a good
way of putting it but
honestly i don't think even in the book
he was a little bit more sympathetic but
i didn't find him really all that
sympathetic in the book either so i
don't think i mean maybe it's just me
but i don't think kubrick's version of
him was that wildly different from the
one in the book and the difference is in
the book he gives his life he redeems
himself at the end he gives his life to
save danny and the mother
he he he
be he he was able to resist the
possession that had overcome him for
long enough to take to kill himself so
they could survive yeah and he ends up
destroying the overlook which like i
said that's that's cool and i like that
but i liked kubrick's decision for the
movie better because to me it made it
scarier yeah i think that was scarier
right i don't know i just like that
better but you know like i said i went
into it but i love the book though the
book is awesome
but
like i said book a movie two different
things you can't like just take a book
usually i mean depending on what the
book is obviously but you can't just
like take a book and like slap the thing
like they're literally on the screen
it's not gonna work out the same it's
two completely different mediums it
doesn't work out the same
zack says uh the 70s movie of cary is
what got me into filmmaking in the first
place can't beat brian de palma for
imagery man yeah i i agree with that
i mean
the 1976 version of carrie that's a
classic and uh pretty that's pretty
faithful to book two now that i'm
thinking about it
i didn't even mind the remake it's not
great but it wasn't terrible but i mean
the [ __ ] spacing the sissy's basic
version is like way better well the
thing about it too is that
the remake
had um
uh what's what's that what's that
chick's name uh
chloe gla grace uh moretz
and
she is cute as a button now i'm not
saying that sissy's basic isn't cute as
button because she is but sissy's basic
is she's beautiful but she's kind of
like weird looking too spooky looking
and so i think that worked a lot better
because i was like i believed that
people would pick on that girl yeah i
didn't believe that anybody would pick
on click uh you know chloe grace moore
it's because because she's cute
kind of [ __ ] skinny
like i said [ __ ] spacey is cute too but
i i can totally believe that somebody
would pick up skinny gaunt kinda
appalachian mountains kind of well she's
freckled and she has like kind of
reddish hair and it's like yeah she's a
little bit gawky and a little bit
awkward it's like it made a lot more
sense to me it's like a ghost kind of
ghostly
looking
i kind of feel like and maybe this
started and because the the carrie
remake i think came out in what 2005
2006 somewhere around there i don't know
but i kind of feel like in the 90s and
the 2000s there was this big thing of
one doing horror remakes and two we're
going to do all these horror remakes but
we're going to put like the most
gorgeous people imaginable in it and
it's just kind of like
depending on the context of the story it
just doesn't work and especially in cary
because it's like this is supposed to be
she's like at the bottom of the social
barrel like everybody picks on her but
she was cute though it says so in the
book yeah but like i said but she's
awkward and shy and it's like you have
to have somebody that they don't have to
be ugly
but they have to be
somebody that you would understand that
other people would constantly pick on
you know what i mean she's she was as
described in the book from what i
remember yeah
she had a super religious mother that
wouldn't let her go anywhere she was
kind of like uh gaunt and skinny and
somebody that was real pale because she
couldn't go outside and she was like a
living ghost and that's what sushi's
basically looked like yeah but she was
cute yeah
and and she was really interested some
people were trying to help her yeah and
but she unbeknownst to everybody else
she had [ __ ] rspk she was [ __ ] the
culture guys [ __ ] sit in focus and
her mom had [ __ ] [ __ ] her up so bad
she ended up [ __ ]
killing people with it burn it all down
burning everything down i can't really i
couldn't really blame her right and then
everybody people in the book she dies
okay well she died in the movie too yeah
but not in the second movie in the
second movie they remember that they
[ __ ] let her live
and uh then uh she evidently
moves on to have a [ __ ] happy life
terrible idea
the [ __ ] whole idea of the book was
that it was a tragedy okay she was an
innocent person who was just caught into
a teenager caught in a bad situation and
she imploded and took everybody with her
yeah but they were kind of guilty
because the whole [ __ ] school had
been [ __ ] with her yeah so she took
everybody with her and it's a warning it
was an anti-bullying message yeah quit
picking on the g yeah quit picking on
the girl yeah they [ __ ] they
people can retaliate
you know no matter what they look like
people can retaliate
don't underestimate people's ability to
retaliate on your ass yeah they might
you don't know they might have [ __ ]
psychic powers yeah that's it well yeah
you know they'll smash your head in
or burn the whole [ __ ] problem down
you always lock all your asses in there
she had to make her mad she had a
psychic talent she could [ __ ] not
only was a psychokinesis she had
pyrokinesis too didn't she couldn't she
make something just burst into flames or
did the fire just
break out because she tore the building
down
yeah i think she based yeah i don't
think she started the fire with her mind
i think that was more of a fire starter
yeah right that was what's in it yeah
she basically just in the in the course
of like everything falling apart like in
the gym like a fire started like with
the microphone like shorting out earlier
yeah
i think that's where the lights fell or
something yeah something like that
but you know weren't there some no
wasn't there some lanterns
when there's some lanterns see i thought
it was just like the the stage lights
and the microphone that like shorted out
i mean it's been like probably a year or
two they couldn't get out because the
fire i think
no they couldn't get out because she
came like doors caved in the doors and
they couldn't get out i think yeah
and it was kind of a misunderstanding
she thought everybody set her up but it
wasn't
well
some of them did cetera but yeah but
like innocent people died in there too
she thought that we're all after see
well that's the thing it's like the one
scene like after the pig's blood falls
on her head hopefully i'm not like
spoiling it for anybody i know it came
out it's like it came out a long time
ago so after the pig's blood falls on
her head
and then she's like looking out and
everybody is laughing at her yeah now
now do we know was everybody actually
laughing at her or was that just her
perception we don't know we don't know
because it looked like everybody was
laughing even like the people that had
been nice to her previously the original
is classic and it's it's really real
close to the book it is it is quite
faithful it is and the dude that was
tried that they picked
to try to bring her out of her shell i
had the same name with his yeah tommy
ross tommy ron tommy played by william
cat the greatest american
here frizzy harry with his big old hair
yeah
you need a wig like that that's what i
need i got one [ __ ] look like peter
frampton yeah like peter frampton comes
alive that's right tommy ross
hearth rob and his girlfriend says
you're gonna go out with carrie
for prom he's like really you want me to
go with her yeah and he's like whoa whoa
okay he's just kind of a dumb guy okay
whatever you say baby
he liked her but he wasn't anything
romantic
i don't think i mean well he just yeah
well he just did it because his
girlfriend said you know i feel really
bad right because she was i mean really
sue
was the only
redeemable well no tommy ross was okay
too those two were like the only
redeemable characters everybody else at
the school was like a shitheal and
carrie thought he was in on it [ __ ]
she kills him too
well you can't blame her for thinking
that
yeah i mean it did kind of seem like
everybody set her up which like i said
they did
but
she just didn't know that like sue and
tommy weren't in on it because everybody
else was in on it and also tommy didn't
even know about i like how they set up
the relationship between her and her mom
was like something out of sybil remember
the remember the [ __ ] book in the
movie civil yeah so it was like that and
i think i think king
maybe used sybil as a [ __ ] template
for how maybe i can't remember when that
came out well i mean the book carrie
came out very early that was his first
novel was it not
he had published a bunch of short
stories prior in like usually in uh
porno mags yeah but i'm pretty sure that
carrie was his first but what was great
about king is that he didn't pull the
shot of his ass whatever the
parapsychology departments were talking
about ucla or whatever usc uh
he's gonna go with that yeah what if
somebody could move things with their
minds
what if somebody could because the
russians said it was happening they had
that girl that could move compasses and
move things
without being able to touch them
evidently um never been debunked
uh and then uh
there were rumors of pyrokinesis people
were investigating pyrokinesis jenny
covered some of that in poultry in a
poultry guys book that she wrote unseen
hand
the case is a little black boy that
could
cause burn spots to appear on the wall
through his frustration
and every house he was in he burned
burned it down
remember that guy a little kid yeah i
wonder whatever happened to him that was
back in the 60s wasn't it 50s i don't
even think it was that long ago wasn't
that long enough i don't think and uh so
parapsychology departments knew that
they said well if you can move a big
object you can move a little object well
you can move you can agitate
molecules fast enough it'll get hot and
it'll [ __ ] spontaneously combust now
that's not happening with the
spontaneous combustion people
that's not paranormal that's just
somebody burning very slowly like a wick
i've seen it
they'll just take a dab
pig and put it on a carpet and put a
blanket over it and with a lighter you
can set that blanket on fire and it'll
burn the fat on that pig and it'll make
that blanket burn and the clothes burn
like a wick
yeah they've done that stuff like about
spontaneous yeah
spontaneous human combustion is not true
yeah
um it's just that br that we did a show
about that a little bit yeah you got to
be fat
that helps
because it's the fat burning because
that's what they like a whip make the
candy and when you see it happening the
flames aren't any higher than like four
or five inches tall they're little bitty
flames yeah you're just kind of it burns
a little slow roasting slow roasting
i'm gonna burn it down to the bone and
it'll look like smells good in here and
it looks like it got real hot but it
didn't get real hot it just burned real
low and slow for a long time because
there wasn't enough oxygen in the room
it consumed a lot of it
so the flames can't get high and it all
just [ __ ] burns out right there in
that spot and when you see it in
time-lapse photos of a pig doing that
you go oh of course yeah you recognize
it you're like of course that's what
that is
but spontaneous combustion inside
[ __ ] pyrokinesis is totally different
that's when somebody uses psychokinesis
to speed up and agitate molecules and if
something burst into flames
now there's never been any reports that
it's as good as what you'd see in the
movies fire starter she wrote
down uh the cases that were known
it just looks like burned spots that
appear on a wall usually
like a brown spot getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and maybe a flame will
come out of it
like the size of a
flame coming out of a damn
zippo light or a big lighter maybe
and then if then it goes out that's
usually what it is
and they'll be everywhere
sometimes it'll happen to clothes inside
of a
dresser drawer
and then it'll actually the fire will
grow
get pretty big
it's an interesting phenomenon
danny rowling said uh tommy knockers
deserves a remake but the same can't be
said for the langoliers ever honestly um
knockers with a move that book wasn't
any good i didn't like i didn't really
like the book either but well like i
said i'm not a big fan and that's like
no ding against king i guess but it's
like i'm not really a big fan of like
alien horror
yeah um it's just not my thing well the
aliens were the best part of that book
but it was just kind of a jumbled book
he's real high and he's it's it's
beating around the bush it's not right i
mean i think i just read it like one
time like a long time ago i remember
liking the story the langoliers but the
movie was pretty
terrible yeah i remember it being
terrible john gore said the mist was
cool yeah that was that was frank
darabont and honestly like the um yeah
the story's good and even though the
ending of the movie is different i like
what he did with the end it's okay i
like that he kind of went camp guy said
also apt pupil is a great uh stephen
king short story yeah that's a really
good one they made a movie out of that
one too with sir ian mckellen in it i
remember the movie being okay but not as
good as the story the problem with the
mist in the the movie the mist
is that it had kind of a happy ending
that was [ __ ] dumb they should have
never done that should have ended like
the book they got out of the supermarket
but they just drove off into a damn fog
and they saw these giant creatures they
were still in that dimension
you know and they didn't know where they
were going
which that's the that's the ending you
want
that way you can make more movies
because i'm sure he planned to [ __ ]
maybe write more books happening in that
area that'd have been a great series of
books it was almost it was kind of love
crafty and yeah like somehow now he
wrote a couple of other lovecrafty and
short stories i feel like i don't think
he ever did any novel novels like in the
lovecraftian universe in that video i
showed but he did do a few short stories
the mist is in the same universe as the
dark tower and a bunch of other ones
because
uh what's mentioned is several other
dimensions that are all interconnected
and the missed dimension is in
that universe
which uh you know it's mentioned in
other stories but i don't haven't read
them
that's a cool idea
camp guy said i think shawshank and the
body are in the same collection of
stories yeah they might both be a night
shift
which i have somewhere
but i can't it's it's probably down
there someplace but i don't know but
yeah but i think both of those stories
are are in there apt pupil i think was
in different seasons which actually
wasn't short stories like four short it
was like four novellas
uh granthars is asking what are three
tenets of being a true goth
three tenets oh there is no such thing
at all
whether or not the goth people like you
uh whether or not you have the right
look are you into like some cool music
or are you just faking it even though a
lot of goths don't listen to gothic
music and
god's appropriate music
okay that's true a lot of stuff we
listen to doesn't it doesn't come from
the goth scene it comes from other [ __ ]
well like i said and i think i brought
this up before but what's interesting is
that people that aren't in the goth
scene like don't really know that much
about our music but we know a lot about
everyone else's music yeah because goth
people or people that are really into
the god scene tend to be like music
very music-centric
and a lot of them don't just like goth
industrial music they like a lot of
other different kinds of music yeah
something about who is the most evil man
besides hitler well who is the worst
person who doesn't have to be a man
who's the worst person who ever lived
minus hitler yeah we're taking him out
of the equation see the thing is the
worst person that ever god there's a lot
of competition in that area people tend
to want to throw these world leaders in
in into the [ __ ] pile of being the
worst people when you look at the
details of the [ __ ] biggest mass
murderers in history if you actually
look at that person on a personal level
there isn't much to those guys this is
institutional evil
those guys are caught up into some
[ __ ] and they don't really
understand the magnitude of [ __ ] what
they're doing because they don't
actually physically see it themselves
they just
hand out some orders
you know what i mean so it's not so much
that they're bad
it's more like that they're just kind of
like sociopaths they don't even think
they fully grasp the reality of a lot of
[ __ ] that they do it's their imagination
who's a lot worse are people who are
doing things physically on their own to
other people which would be serial
killers they're a lot worse
i mean you're not doing the same amount
of damage that's what i'm saying like
you could argue characters are a lot
worse yeah yeah i get what you're saying
yeah i mean i think people mostly like
jump to world leaders just because like
i said they're acting on a world stage
so they potentially have a lot of people
have a lot more impact on the world at
large whereas a serial killer as shitty
as that is yeah i mean might just kill
like 30 or 40 20 thirty forty people in
one
relatively thick area of the lot worse
of the globe but yeah i characters are a
lot worse
those world leaders that are doing that
[ __ ]
when you're dealing with somebody that
might be slightly psychopath or
sociopathic they're very detached from
what they're doing they're working in
theories inside their head and they
think they're doing the right thing to
help mankind or their people so they
just hand out these orders and then they
[ __ ] it goes through the system and
the system's telling them how great they
are so they don't really have any damn
impact like mao was sure that he was a
genius even though his people were
[ __ ] starving well he didn't have
anything he didn't have anybody that had
the balls to tell him was like [ __ ] you
talk they were [ __ ] terrified
you're [ __ ] terrified of him you are
a crazy person have you locked up and
[ __ ] and you died if they locked you
up you know i kind of feel like people
like that to a large not all of them
obviously because some of them are just
like way the [ __ ] delusional whatever
but i kind of feel like people like that
i think deep down
they know that they're terrible evil
people and i think that that's why
they're just kind of like anybody that
says bad [ __ ] about me i'm just gonna
like put him in prison or i'm gonna
execute him or whatever because you know
you don't want to hear it
you know you're a terrible person i
don't know you just don't want to hear
it you want everybody kissing your ass i
think you're overestimating them i i
think you're overestimating them i think
i think most likely what it is is
they're just really banal
they're just
you're reading into them there's not a
lot to them there wasn't much to any of
those guys stalin there wasn't much to
him
um they had a lot of power but he was
just street thug
you know he was
well admired he was just a bank robber
who was assassinating people during the
revolution
he ended up in a damn intelligence
agency and realized that he could weasel
his way to the top
uh but he thought he was doing good for
russia
you know he thought everybody else was
just weak you know
well a lot of villains think they're
doing good that's why they're villains
yeah yeah so this whole thing about the
deep down he knows is a terrible person
no i think stalin thought he was great
that he was awesome no i'm not saying
that i'm just saying that i'm just
saying on an unconscious level
he might actually and it's causing him
to act out i act out i don't think that
he knows that on any kind of like
conscious level i don't think that he
knows that he's a terrible person based
on but he's acting on some unconscious
based on everything i'm seeing through
mao
stalin hitler those are the heavy
hitters
um in terms of just sheer numbers
those dudes thought they were [ __ ]
god's gift
they thought everybody they killed
deserved it that they were all bad that
they had to go but how much of that was
justification though like other people
were justifying it for them they had
some yeah but like i said they had
psycho fence all but the reason that
they had that was because they didn't
want to hear it
they were just kind of like i just i
just want to hear it it wasn't just them
there was all this there was a whole
society of a bunch of rats and psycho
fans and they're caught up into this
mass movement like a cult
you know yeah it's very much they were
cult leaders all those all those three
they they lived in an entourage it was
had kind of like cult roots
that had
they okay look here's a great example
the same kind of person who's not a
world leader david miscavige
it's exactly the same way david
miscavige doesn't think his [ __ ] stinks
at all
and he does he even poop no that dude
doesn't even pop he could kill it no he
doesn't even david miscavige could kill
millions of people and he goes well
they're walks
they're sps we have to
and and he'd sleep soundly like it never
even happened by the way british people
that is what scientologists call the
rest of us yeah yeah which i i
understand that's a british yeah it's a
uh that's a racist term it's a racist
term in england in england
i don't know about nowadays but in
scientology it means non-scientologist
yeah which which would be kind of like
kind of like mean but i think they used
that nomenclature specifically because
it was a racist slur maybe i don't know
i can't i can't i can't [ __ ] tell you
what scientologists think
where their words come from they
probably don't know anything about
england all right or what that means no
i think they do do they okay i think
they do they use it to mean i think they
know exactly why they use that term they
use it to mean non-scientologists
and uh
a non-scientologist is a it is it would
be like the equivalent in islam would be
kind of like a uh what do they call it a
kafir or a [ __ ] uh a non
non-muslim a non-believer well what's
another word they use for that uh
an apostate no apostate somebody leaves
the religion well yeah i know that
somebody who is never in the religion
like a non-entity uh what do they call
it um [ __ ]
uh it wouldn't even be a heretic a
heretic is somebody who's preaching
heresy a reverse [ __ ] religious
narrative
in christianity would be heathen
uh so no david miscavige if he ever got
world power and tried to institute
scientology let's try to not let that
happen
the scientologists would kill almost all
of us
oh i'm sure i i have no absolutely no
doubt about it yeah and they would be i
worked with the [ __ ] right i
would not put it right
and they would not see it as a crime
they would see it as a great thing
improving humanity to get rid of all
these bad people these people are evil
and they got to go
because we're trying to clear the planet
and save these [ __ ] souls and go to
the bridge of [ __ ] no return whatever
the [ __ ] what do they call that british
bridge the total freedom and you can't
have that with all these [ __ ] the
bridge over the river i don't know yeah
right yeah i can't have that with all
these so i like to use scientology
because it's more of a neutral term
people get all hyped up about communism
and nazism because it's politics and
people are childish about politics
there's no difference between politics
and religion it's the same thing
but you can look at a religion cult
like scientology if they got into power
we'd be dead
they would have no problem killing us
because they see it they see it as
improving the earth like i said i have
no doubt about liberating the earth from
evil is how they would see it
right and
you know you really got to watch anybody
that has that kind of like mindset
anybody that would kind of get into
scientology and i've talked about this
before because i worked with the
[ __ ] i would not trust them as
far as i could throw them which is not
very far so this that you're so this
projection of morality into them of like
well they know they're bad people deep
down no they don't
no they are not believers i'm not saying
that i'm saying some of them might some
of them might maybe but the thing about
it is that i don't know like i said the
it's the world's a big place so you know
everybody has kind of their own thing
going on
some people have a little bit more
self-reflection than other people do but
i'm not saying that they consciously
know
that they're terrible people i don't
think they consciously know that
i think but i think unconsciously
somewhere
that is a factor and that is making them
act out but they if you ask them to
explain it they wouldn't be able to
explain it because they don't it's not
conscious they would explain it like
this well i have to do these evil things
it's the only way to get rid of these
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying that's
what they would say consciously right
but like i'm saying unconsciously i
think that that might be coming from a
place of
self-loathing
well that would be everybody
because everybody's kind of doing that
well i mean everyone's self-loathing but
a very very small percentage of people
actually have to like i have to kill
these piece of [ __ ] nazis the men the
women and the children it's the same
[ __ ] thing
i mean but the thing about look
everybody has some degree of
self-loathing okay you do i do everyone
does
but it's only thankfully it's only like
a relatively small percentage that
causes that person to be like well i'm
gonna kill every [ __ ] because
you know for whatever reason that they
use to justify it i would never do that
in a million years i would never i would
i would die before i would [ __ ] do
that it's just not in me it's just not
and
but you know you can't say the same but
everybody's not like me but you know
what i mean but
that's kind of where i'm coming from
with that but i'm just i'm not saying
they consciously realize
and that's why they're acting that way
i'm just saying that it's an unconscious
thing that they're acting on but they
don't realize that they're acting on it
because they're not really that
self-reflective psychopaths sociopaths
they tend to really not have a lot of uh
you know introspection or
self-reflection that's kind of one of
their main problems i feel like all i
know is that some people have to go
some people are threatening me the
people i care about family members the
civilizations i like and you can't
reason with them so they're gonna have
to go
but i'm not the only one that thinks
like that the ones that are trying to
[ __ ] kill me are thinking that
having a job in the [ __ ] army
infantry you just become used to that
and then you start going like well i
don't really care who's right and wrong
i just care about my point of view
we all going to die eventually anyway we
only live for a certain amount of time
nature will sort it out
yeah but i come to imagine somebody
tries to come in here and [ __ ] kill
you and pokey and this and that i'm not
gonna reason it out well neither would i
most people you wouldn't want to die
most people would right
because that's obvious because that's
obviously somebody that is
you know if they don't even if they
don't know you particularly and they're
just coming in here for whatever other
reason i mean obviously that's
justifiable i don't think anybody would
argue they they already have their reach
right but are those libraries legitimate
in their minds who knows but in their
minds they probably think it is those
people stole that wealth i'm going to
take it back from them
yeah they'll they'll justify anything
but wealth i don't have any wealth yeah
this wealth where this is more like debt
[ __ ] hundreds of thousands
[Laughter]
but you're welcome too dealing with
people that are [ __ ] will say
anything to themselves to justify i kind
of feel like if anybody did that it
would probably just be more like we're
going to steal some [ __ ] or we're going
to rape somebody so exactly exactly but
so it's so it's not going to be like any
larger like grand scheme there's not
going to be any bigger way
what they tend to do is those there's an
us and them mentality we deserve to
take from them that almost always
that's how they that's how they get up
the courage to do it
yeah i guess but you know what i mean
there's like uh grandparents said
there's a fad going around i mean i
haven't heard about it so it can't be
that big of a fad but uh called no poop
july what
did five people didn't find people on
tick tock come up with that and then
like everybody's reporting on it like
it's a big trend you just hold it in all
yeah where people intentionally avoid
evacuating their bowels please don't do
that
you're gonna get in big trouble
well the thing about it that's the thing
and this it's not just instagram and
tick tock and this has been going on
since i can remember there's always kind
of like somebody will find like some
stupid extreme thing yeah like on take
like so look at this idiot doing this
and then they find another idiot doing
it and they're like oh my god it's a
trend now i'm like oh two people is a
trend now but like i said they're just
writing a story
what's up so i haven't seen you in a
while what's up sly he said uh love your
blue hair jenny thank you um this is i
liked the original blue wig i got so
much
that i bought this second one this is a
new one this is the first time i worn it
because
the old one i mean i can still wear the
old one but i've worn it out so many
times that i feel like it's kind of
getting like a little bit janky looking
you know what i mean because they're
only like 20 dollar wigs you know what i
mean you can only wear them several
times before they start getting like
sweaty and knotted holy parachute doom
sees it like i do because every atrocity
throughout history
has journals where the perpetrators
kept it they wrote about and described
it as an honorable struggle that they
were engaged in no different from well
it's very easy to do horrible [ __ ] when
you dehumanize your
enemies and they all do it basically
well because in a way
i know this is weird to say
but in a way it kind of makes me bet
feel better that people actually have to
do that because people could just like
kill people without even like there's
like yeah they're humans too who [ __ ]
cares i'm gonna kill them then that
might be a little upsetting but the fact
that they actually have to
strategically go to oh well they're
sub-human or they're not you know what i
mean they're not like me or they're
something like that they have to like
compartmentalize they have to make that
different than them like to do
what they're doing to them like they
have to dehumanize them in some fashion
so
that just goes to show it's like that's
not like a natural
i don't know if i'd say it's not a
natural proclivity but i'm just saying
that well i'm just saying that to
compartmentalize yeah i'm just saying
that it's harder for them to do it's
harder for them to do like without
coming up with all these justifications
you could go back 2 000 years and the
romans the romans were [ __ ] basically
demonizing thracians and [ __ ] gulls
okay
as
barbarians you know [ __ ] kind of
sub-human savages
so they go in there and [ __ ]
slaughter and conquer them
100 years later
they reverse all that propaganda that
they were talking about they don't even
have people dressing up as thracians or
gals in the arena anymore because now
they're all honorable roman citizens now
you know so it's just the way it always
has been
for
the situation changes they were in
conflict with the neighbors
probably the conflict was going both
sides they're probably both picking on
each other because they're just normal
human competition you know for land
land wealth resources
so they come into conflict and both
sides are demonizing demonizing each
other i'm sure the gauls and the
thracians demonize the [ __ ] romans
too
but then eventually peace comes
after somebody wins a fight
you know and the gauls and the thracians
got absorbed by the empire
but then they just become romans
they're running for office and [ __ ] they
got baths they're wearing the same
clothes speak the same language
well it's kind of like a thing where
happened to our states here in the
united states i was just gonna say i was
i was kind of thinking about that
earlier because i was thinking about you
go back uh you know 150 years um even in
the united states like italians irish
stuff like that were not even really
seen as white people yeah and then now
everybody's white slowly slowly latinos
are becoming white people
they're becoming the same well we're
kind of seeing it happen in real time
because they're all interbreeding with
one another they're all in america well
like i said it was kind of like it just
happens it's you know it's very slow but
it does we go to the club man and
[ __ ] hang out with all our friends
and i gotta [ __ ] pause sometimes and
realize that [ __ ] [ __ ] half of them
are half of them are at least half
latino
but we don't think like that we don't
look at people by their races
you know but we're in florida
this is a melting pot between basically
the irish and [ __ ] irish and central
americans well to think about it and i
kind of feel like well florida and they
make some good-looking people when they
marry they [ __ ] look great you know i
got pictures of them
you know and it's just but you don't
think of it to us they just look like my
people what people you know like
like you don't think about well that
person's half italian you just don't
think like that
i didn't even think like that back in
the 70s you don't think honestly the
first time that i remember this being a
thing this is like crazy
i was a kid i think i was maybe 10 or 11
and somebody had given me this book it
was like some kind of like teen romance
kind of thing or something like that
which wasn't usually my thing i usually
like mysteries or ghost stories or
whatever but i read it and it was pretty
good
and the and this is probably like back
in the late 70s or early 80s
and i was reading it and the mother of
the main character
was like super racist and was like
racist against italians yeah and i was
like reading that book because i think
the book was written in the 1950s yeah
and i was just like well those days have
changed
like i didn't get it like i was just
kind of like italian what yeah like that
it did it made notes
ethnic groups it made no sense to me at
all yeah
and the same thing happened when i read
like some old judy bloom books like
there's one called um what the [ __ ] was
the name of that book starring sally j
friedman as herself and it was kind of
like about um it was about a jewish girl
and she was kind of like the conflicts
that she kind of came into like with her
you know more christian like
counterparts or whatever and it was just
kind of like
but she's just like a person like there
would really didn't seem like any
difference and i was just kind of like i
don't know i didn't get it which is
weird because
not you know not gonna be mean but like
my grandpa was like super super racist
oh my goodness so racist and like so i
understood the concept of that but it's
just like i had never heard anybody like
be racist against like other white
people before yeah so like so i just
thought that was like super weird like i
totally didn't get it khan's talking
about how sweet those morenas are morena
is kind of like a brunette okay it's
kind of a light-skinned dark-haired
latina type
hispanic type woman that's what he's
talking about oh yeah there and he was
funny about khan khan showed me a
picture of his mom
when his mom was young and she is a
spittin image spitting image of laura
really laura ross looks just like her
when i saw the picture and the post was
near one of lora's posts
and it said you know something about him
his mom you know and it was like oh my
god our friend laura is your mom no
i got confused i think
i think tom is writing it in spanish
sometimes you know because i just
absorbed spanish like it was portuguese
and it's english it all comes to come
together and i got confused i thought it
was laura talking about her mom no it
was oh okay it was
it was [ __ ] khan of atlanta his name
is air jair was talking about i don't
think mario
damn they look insane
yeah and i showed he showed um khan a
picture of laura and he's like oh yeah
it does look like hormone
and he's that's tijuana mexico and she
was from spain
spain and where
and poland
she was a mix of spanish and poland and
polish nice stuff mom's from poland yeah
uh sebastian saying oh we were talking
about how scientologists call
non-scientologists hogs and i was asking
is that still a racist term in the uk
sebastian moran says yes indeed it is
still a racist term here that's what i
thought that's what i thought i mean i
knew it was like because i last time i
was in the uk was probably like 2009 and
i remember it was still a racist storm
then but yeah yeah scientologists are
just generic they're kind of an
unknowing people they just repeat what
what other scientologists say well they
live in a bubble they're very much in a
bubble it's like a military style bubble
i worked with them it's super weird yeah
they don't know anything that's going on
like in the real world at all they use
that term to basically just mean um
[ __ ] uh uh
heathen you know non non-scientologist
uh you know but like in many cults it's
just kind of a way of
oh that's that's
because they think that anyone who is
not a scientologist is ignorant and
barbaric savage
which is hilarious because they're not
dumb yeah yeah they don't know they
don't know [ __ ] about anything they
don't know [ __ ] and like i said it's
and i think the main thing and a lot of
things piss me off in this life okay but
i think the main thing that pisses me
off probably more than anything else
is dumb ass people that think they're
smarter than everybody that makes me so
so angry and i because i think because
there's a lot of that though well no i
know like dunning-kruger syndrome that
it's a thing and oh my god it makes me
so so mad because i'm just kind of like
kind of i worked like i said i worked
with them a long time i lived in
clearwater and the fact that they're so
ignorant
and yet
they walk around like they know
everything and they're better than
everybody i'm just like do you guys
really not i'm like oh my god you guys
are like [ __ ] so clueless it's like
not even i saw a study on that that
syndrome doesn't quite
work but it it does kind of describe
what's happening but i saw a program on
i can't remember what the video was
where they actually did the statistics
they did iq tests
they notice that people
who have iqs of like
between 105 and 115 maybe 120 around the
time are
most mostly have that effect you're
talking about
they think everybody else is dumber than
them they think they're called midwits
that's the [ __ ] real um they're smart
enough to be trained like like any other
smart animal but they don't have much in
introspection they think everybody's
dumber than them
people that are smarter than them are
dumber than them but it's a certain
personality type that falls within that
iq page
and the process
they're not all like that it's just a
certain personality type that is within
that iq range they have don't have any
introspection no mind's eye either they
like they don't have any when they think
of things there's no visual
representation in their mind in other
words there's no imagination
no ability to look inward at all
and they say that
lower iq people actually do better on a
lot of tasks than those people i could
see that because they are overestimating
their own intelligence a lot and well
yeah that's what i mean that's what
dunning is and then they underestimate
everybody else's intelligence but here's
one of the main attributes is that
they're entirely fixated on titles and
credentials
like um
they did a thing on youtube where
this girl thinks she's the smartest
thing ever because she has a degree and
she's judging everybody else based on
their degree
and she's trying to rank everybody else
in the class of who's the lowest and she
puts the military guy at the lowest
all right because he was in the military
turned out his iq score was up towards
the top it was just just right
underneath the other dude who was like
uh you know [ __ ] like 140 445 iq this
dude's like a 135.
but just because his title was
ex-military she thought that he must be
dumb
well see the thing about it and what
they found with dunning-kruger syndrome
is that people who are
kind of just smart enough like you said
a midwit yeah that are just kind of like
smart enough to like know what's going
on but not all that smart the thing
about it is that people that are
actually smart
usually
usually um have some kind of like
introspection and like self-deprecation
because if you're really smart you
understand
how much you don't know and that there's
other kinds of intelligence and that
that's what i'm saying so i kind of feel
like i kind of judge intelligence by
like how much do you understand that
like there's so much that you don't know
so i kind of feel like
that's kind of the cutoff the problem
with people that have done in kruger
syndrome is that they're just smart
enough to be like hey i'm really smart
but not smart enough to realize that
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that they don't
know so they think that they know
everything yeah it's like that you're
right you know what i mean there are
there are guys
that are [ __ ]
heavily degreed
they can figure out a [ __ ] super
complex task i mean they're [ __ ]
smart
but they cannot predict how other people
will behave under certain circumstances
they have no
human engineering skills well everybody
is good at different things right you
know right and then they got dudes who
are in the hood
totally illiterate
they have master game
that could [ __ ] beat you at chess
that could think rings around you in
practic in practical means lie cheat
steal and win
and a dude can barely read
or not read
but it's so charismatic and so
so good at com
at hustling and figure out and and being
able to predict what a person would do
their their intelligence effective their
effective intelligence is very high
and here's the funny thing you'd rather
be around that dude than the [ __ ]
genius you know what i mean then the
so-called g
yeah i'd rather hang out with this dude
well like i said it's just kind of like
skills you know this is why i'm a big
advocate of
i just like take people as they come you
know what i mean it's just kind of like
i don't know like it doesn't really
matter what your credentials are or what
you look like or anything like that like
what are you like
yeah i mean everybody has their own [ __ ]
going on everybody is like good at
certain things and not good at other
certain like everybody's different so
it's just kind of like you kind of have
to just take everybody as an individual
you can't generalize you can't you can't
do anything like i know it's harder but
you just can't do that because everybody
you don't know what you're getting into
with that person every single person has
a million different things going on and
you don't really know
john smith said in self-defense classes
they now teach women to think of an
attacker as an it this can be difficult
as the person hurting them is most
likely someone they know
yeah i mean i get why they do that like
it probably makes it easier particularly
for women i guess like you know because
generally i guess it's like kind of
harder for like a woman to like hurt
somebody that's not but i don't think
anybody would have a hard time like
hurting somebody that was a stranger
but
yeah that might kind of like shoot you
in the ass because
i mean the reality of it is
80 90 percent of the time the person
hurting you is gonna be
somebody you know like a co-worker or an
ex-boyfriend or something like that so
i don't know if like teaching them to
see see that person is the same kind of
[ __ ] in the newer
i mean
i can see why they're doing that like
it's not a bad idea i'm just saying that
they have they would probably have to
like modify the stuff for like this
situation oh hold on let me tell them
something
the us army hasn't won a war in a long
long [ __ ] time it's because it was
never really designed to it's designed
to make money for the military
industrial complex and make rich guys
richer and keep us in these [ __ ]
foreign projects money making projects
for a long time
at the expense of [ __ ]
basically poor southern guys okay
they're dying for it but you'll give
them little pieces of colored ribbon to
wear on their [ __ ] to make them feel
important it's a [ __ ] sad situation
because when i joined i thought i was
helping america
during the first gulf war
not really
the united states didn't really get
anything out of that neither did it
neither did we
um and then it progressively got worse i
think it's coming to an end i don't
think people are going to allow
the criminal cartels that run this
[ __ ] [ __ ] to continue these senseless
senseless [ __ ] [ __ ] up the whole
middle east over basically nothing bunch
of lies empire of lies really what this
is they got us right on it
but what they were telling guys during
my time is they were trying to [ __ ]
just foment lots of hatred into you
to hate the enemy because to make it a
lot easier on you to kill this enemy in
a combat arms environment
and that that does work
it works
but you can only get guys to do that for
so long
all right now what they're telling to do
is don't kill the enemy per se you're
doing this to protect the friend next to
you i think that's even worse because
now you're lying to them
because you've got them there in these
other countries under false presences to
begin with you're shoving
western democracies down the throats of
middle eastern people that don't want
democracy they want theocracy this is
their culture and this is they've been
that way for a long time they they look
at our medium our media and everything
on television and the porn in our
society and they [ __ ] hate that they
they do not want that at all they want
they want islam
hey this is what they choose
let them choose it that's why we're
losing
you cannot force our ways on other
people
you're killing people to force our ways
on other people that's just the [ __ ]
line we weren't there to bring democracy
in those people we were there to make
money
military contracts
so
you can't rationalize murder
really
it's it's it's an animal thing
you're fighting you're either defending
or attacking
when you start all these high-minded
lies you're just making it worse if you
ask me
it's better to face the truth
because if you're facing the truth
you won't do something that you can't
live with
if you give them these lies you'll be
able to manipulate these dudes and you
know dudes like me into doing [ __ ] it
really doesn't benefit me or our people
here in the united states
in the end it's gonna come it came back
to bite us in the ass
all right
you're going to be a multipolar world
now because we've lost our mojo
ran this [ __ ] into the ground
you know you guys are going to see
russia and china are going to run this
in india
they got a future i don't think we
really do not in the way that we did
but um that's what i'm i'm saying
tell yourself the truth if you're a
woman and dude's beating your ass kill
that you defend yourself if you got to
kill him to save yourself you you face
it do it
you know don't let some dude kill you
you know you should think highly of
yourself but here's the thing if you're
in an abusive relationship like that
what are you doing there
you should have been gone
you know
well maybe there's reasons why they
can't we need to get out of that well
yeah i'm just saying yeah you need to
get out of that
but i'm not everybody attacked me i'm
seeing these guys man dude jumps behind
the counter with a [ __ ] gun an old
man pulls out a knife and stabs that
dude in the throat and throat and then
they [ __ ] want to charge him with
murder [ __ ] no
if a dude's jumping over the counter at
me and points a gun at me i gotta assume
he's trying to kill me that's it i'm a
[ __ ] it's a fight to the death
you know
so i
the whole [ __ ] system is [ __ ]
unraveling you know because it just
doesn't have any goddamn
it's not didn't have any legitimacy
too open to interpretation
john smith says i wish i had 10 of the
self-confidence that dumb people have
i've thought about that kind of thing
like lots of times yeah but i don't
think i would trade i mean i've got
issues but
i don't know i don't think i would like
i know that i'm not i'm not super
self-confident i'm like always like
denigrating ways i'm just like kind of
used to that it's probably like
th that that [ __ ] hor the horses have
left the barn at this point because i'm
like too old but i don't think when i
think about it i'm like would i want to
be yeah but would i want to be different
i don't think i would i don't really
like i don't really like people yeah
that are
dumb or ignorant or whatever but are
over confident or like are proud of
being dumb i don't like those kind of
things
so it's like i don't really want to be
like that i wouldn't want to be that's
an extreme
that's an extreme explanation of what's
happening here's a better way of looking
at it
um i read um i think it came from war as
i knew it what i'm getting ready quote
um
george patton general george patton
wrote a book called war as i know it and
i think what i'm telling you about came
from that book it's been a long time
since i've read the book
world war ii was one of the greatest
from from from
the american point of view was one of
the greatest [ __ ] um
uh
programs of socialism ever
they took all these dudes into the
military and [ __ ] iq tested them
job did job placement their [ __ ] hr
was badass and then they kept
track of all these guys through their
military careers and then hire people to
come in and do studies on the military
men
of world war ii to try to figure out how
to make a better army in the future
and one of the things that they noticed
is that in battlefield commanders
as their iqs passed about 135 or 140
their battle victories declined
what was best was between 110 and about
130 iq
if it was if their iqs were greater than
that they would start losing on the
battlefield
and they tried to figure out why
and the reason why i know why they
started to overthink themselves yeah duh
overthinking themselves right is
they would see got troops in the open
doing something in formation and they go
oh that's got to be a trap the thing
about well the thing about
really intelligent people
is that
their brains immediately go to like the
50 million different things that could
go wrong right like all of the
contingencies this could happen that
could happen this could happen this
could which is good yeah
to an extent yeah uh over a certain uh
you know time though it's just it it
ends up like biting you in the ass yeah
what what they noticed was is you needed
for a battlefield commander you had to
have the iq that was good enough to do
organization but not so good that you
were like you were stopping stepping on
your dick so when you saw troops in the
open again you didn't you didn't go oh
this has to be a trap because who would
put troops out in the open like that no
we have to start doing a battle flight
no the dudes that actually one was like
there they are attack
that those guys [ __ ] actually were
the yeah they were in the open because
they [ __ ] up they were like i said
yeah i wouldn't want to be different
because like look i am like a champion
overthinker okay i will think of like
four i will you give me a situation i
will give you 40 different ways that
could go sideways
and i just like and it i try not to step
on my own dick it it does happen still
but i do tend to overthink everything
i try to you know i've tried to like be
better about it over the years and i've
kind of gotten over it a little bit but
so i do like understand that
but i can understand like in a military
situation that might not be the ideal
the ideal way of looking at things i
mean to an extent yeah that's probably
good it's like because you can
think of like uh you know bad [ __ ] like
the way [ __ ] could go wrong that maybe
other people didn't think of
you know up to a point that's probably
good but after that point it's probably
just like well you're just getting in
your own way so yeah i can see that
um
uh but yeah i do
i do notice that like people that
like i said dunning-fruit dunning-kruger
syndrome
people that sometimes are not that
bright seem like super super confident
sometimes it helps them sometimes not so
much but like i said i really wouldn't
want to be
i don't know i've thought about it would
i want to be different than i am even
though the way i am is a pain in the ass
nah
i'm all right i'm right the way i am i
don't want to be different
you know so bethena said in the cult i
grew up in worldly was the name for
non-believers yeah i'd heard that i've
heard that terminology before
and like i said it's
that's kind of like an okay term because
it's not
inherently denigrating i mean you're
talking about world of the world that's
not really that insulting so i'm not
insulted i'd be more insulted by
somebody calling me
a [ __ ] like the [ __ ] scientologists do
because that's like i said that's a
racist term and i'm pretty sure they
knew that when they coined it pretty
sure tom has given them the benefit of
the doubt i'm not i'm pretty sure they
knew that was a racist term because it
was pretty well known
as i knew it was a racist term and i'm
not even from the uk so you know i'm
just saying i think they knew um but you
know maybe they thought they'd get away
with it was well it's not a racist term
in the united states although it might
have been at some point
in history
grantor says do some goths look at
mundanes like scientologists look at
non-themes
that's a funny question
um
sometimes well like i said it depends
we've kind of got into this before where
it's like look if you just look like a
normal ass person
i'm not
right out the gate gonna judge you i
mean i'm just kind of like hey you're
just doing your thing i'm doing my thing
it's all good
um
the only time that i kind of get like
judgy about it is if you're being a
douche about it or if you're trying to
like draw attention to the fact that
you know and i feel like nowadays
we get that a lot like at mannequins
because like i said you get a lot of
like people wandering in
and you kind of have a thing where
people who
like i said i don't have an issue at all
like with people that come in like
looking normal ass
but they just like you know drink at the
bar and dance like a normal ass person
the problem arises when you come in
looking like that
and then you come and act in an ass
like you just come trying to get
attention or trying to get attention i
don't like people that like try to like
go out of their way to get attention i
don't really like that um and it makes
me and it gives me great delight to
ignore you with
extreme prejudice because it's like i
know you want my attention and i'm just
like not gonna michael shearer says hey
tom a good patent book is a genius for
war i don't i've read that one i just
knew wars i knew it i'll check out
genius for war yeah you must be way
ahead of me because i feel like my chat
stopped a while back
no duh i know but it's not scrolling
that's why i said that okay i know how
to scroll but i'm just saying that it's
not scrolling
so
i mean we're still streaming right
we're still streaming right now okay all
right
it must be just the chop then so just
tell me if i like missed some stuff yeah
granthar's asked uh do some goths look
at mundanes like scientologists look at
non-thetans and i was like uh kinda
that's what i said kinda
well like i said it's not it's not that
we're inherently judgmental club not out
of the club in the club
well like outside of the club i don't
even like notice yeah people because
like like i said normal people kind of
like y'all look the same so it's just
kind of like i don't it doesn't bother
me but like if you come in the club
looking normal i'll maybe glance at you
and be like yeah whatever but i won't
think about it
other than that but now if you start
acting an ass and try to like draw
attention to yourself then yeah i'm
going to notice and yeah i'm going to
start judging you then but other than
that now
other than that like what i don't care
trust how you want
it's like you're not me so
whether i address how i want you dress
how you want yeah john says yeah success
by any metrics is a certain measurement
intelligence that's right
if you can make a lot of money become
successful there's some kind of
intelligence happening there even if
it's just a physical intelligence like
you're an athlete or a charismatic
intelligence like you're a you're an
entertainer it's called uh genius of
human engineering you can get what you
want by being a certain way and people
will reward you the united states has a
huge [ __ ] celebrity culture if you
entertain people in some way you're
loved and you get success
that that in itself is a form of
intelligence can't buy that intelligence
well and i kind of like that nowadays
people understand that there are many
different kinds of intelligence it's not
just one kind yeah
can i please after all this time we've
been like going for more than two hours
uh is murder hornet's still here right
yeah so he sent me this and i wanted to
show it on the show
i wanted to show it on the show look at
this you guys
look how [ __ ] cool that is i just got
it yesterday
yeah he sent me that on a box
yesterday that's epic so i told him i
was like i'm gonna show it on the show
because that's like [ __ ] rad
but yeah
just wanted to show it
because it's cool it's like right here i
love that skirt
yeah i'm like way behind i'm not getting
like updates
on the live chat you might want to uh
refresh the chat
okay okay there we go
there we go
holy [ __ ]
okay yeah i was way behind i was way
behind
now i got to catch you yeah sorry i got
a ocp shirt ocp communications this is
the only choice
i'm selling these twenty dollars any any
size you want
so i made that i made that from the
actual you know the ocp ad that was in
robocop yeah i did a screenshot okay of
that and
traced it
in illustrator
so it looks exactly like that yeah
it looks exactly size of your choice i
can ship it out in a couple days
probably
man uh 20 oh man mark sent us another
ten dollars oh thank you mark you can
see that he's wrecked
how do you see that thank you so much oh
yeah yeah i'm like way behind okay yeah
i'm way back
so sorry about that i gotta wait my like
my chat got stuck yeah my chat got stuck
no ocp not opp
yeah that's what scp was i don't know
why i was in like
omni are you down with opp yeah omni
consumer products that's from robocop
yeah that was the company that made the
damn ed 209 and the [ __ ] robocop
himself it was uh the omni consumer
products the corporation's so big it
made everything omni consumer products
it makes every [ __ ] thing i don't
know if it made the cars though did it
no i don't i think the cars were made by
somebody
let's see
john guerra said you can always dumb
yourself down no no that's hard nah hard
to dump yourself down i mean i'd rather
what you are i'd rather just be me it's
much easier and i'm too lazy i'm too
lazy to like make all that [ __ ]
effort come on
like either either take me as you find
me or [ __ ] off that's that's kind of how
i've gotten to a point at this you know
i'm old so i i don't have the patience
for that kind of [ __ ] anymore pretending
to be something i'm not
agnes lamp said i like you guys we work
from home we don't need to [ __ ] do
anything that's what we work for
ourselves i can do whatever the hell i
want we're free now
i mean we're broke but we're so freaked
out
right off mower with headlights right on
mower with a headlight with a drink
drink thing cup thing in on it yeah and
you can like you can drink if you could
mow the lawn yeah oh my god
yeah it happens
i mean it hasn't happened yet you were
sober the first time
but
you've not been sober sober
man
we told the story didn't we about last
saturday
i don't remember what happened last
saturday yeah no [ __ ] you don't oh oh
yeah
no [ __ ] you don't i told him the next
day because i was sober a bunch of [ __ ]
happened that night
and um
we maybe we need to reiterate maybe some
people were not here
come back when we're not here i come
back from the club we went to barbarella
on saturday night which is like the 80s
new wave which is honestly my favorite
night i really do like the 80s new wave
night it's a it's a good crowd it's good
music
it's just it's fun you know it's fun
so
i go there the new barbarella location
they don't have well he has a liquor
license but he doesn't have
what is it he doesn't he has a liquor
license because he ran the ship downtown
for like 35 years but he can't run it
until after a certain amount of time or
whatever so they only have
the little
canned like white claw type [ __ ] yeah
you know what i'm saying so they only
have that yeah they're weak as [ __ ] well
and that's what i'm saying they're like
five percent alcohol so honestly we got
there right when they opened we were
like the first people there i think
and uh so i had one drink at 9 30. i had
one drink at 10 30 and then i just drank
water the rest of the night we don't
leave to like 1 30 or 2 in the in the
middle of night
so i was completely sober
tom
drank
uh i lost track of unless you drank i
was slamming him you were
i have not seen him that drunk in a very
very very long time and it wasn't even a
hard liquor it was just kind of like
like canned mojitos and beer yes
[ __ ] and [ __ ] like that and holy
crap because the [ __ ] was so weak i was
slamming it that he just kept on i
wasn't really respecting it i just get a
mojito and i just [ __ ] chug it yeah
go get another one
and because it was so tasty and and and
i'm like man it's just so funny you
gotta watch that [ __ ] i gotta slam by
that [ __ ]
and then a bunch of [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
happen man they're having fun that night
oh a bunch of weird [ __ ] first thing
that happened after after i'm starting
to get a slam
my buddy scott shows up with a trans
female
date he was just scott was just here
yeah scott was [ __ ] wrong scott's a
heavyset older dude who's got all this
[ __ ] money well he's your age yeah or
a year or two younger yeah he's younger
than me but he doesn't look all right
anyway
he shows up with a trans female girl
ashley ashley she's like 23.
yeah she was very young yeah she seemed
cool she's a little weird but she was
and
she's kind of like on the clock like
she's working for him you know what i
mean so i won't call her an escort but
she was just
being like a [ __ ] professional valet
[ __ ]
she starts flirting with me and [ __ ]
scott is [ __ ] getting jealous and
whatever man if i got his [ __ ] i go to
the [ __ ] restroom she follows me in
there and [ __ ] tries to [ __ ] throw
down and says look i got a girlfriend
she goes i know i love her i'm gonna
[ __ ] her too
yeah yeah and i was like
she was like she was funny though she
was trying to get me involved in
witchcraft yeah trying to get her to
always nice to know she wanted to do
some witches you come out here she's you
want me to hold that and i says no i got
it i got it i'll show her yeah
i'll show it to you i mean we did that
but don't [ __ ] up the camera because you
made that you made it go all dark before
oh [ __ ] oh wednesday so don't do it it's
not on his phone okay don't worry about
it yeah
just use your imagination
wait a minute wait i think i sent i
think i sent a photograph
to um i can i got it yeah so all that
kind of stuff goes on
all that kind of stuff goes on
and then um hold on
because scott sent me some photographs
over so
[ __ ]
come on let's close that
how long is this going to take no just
talk should i talk
should i go to the bathroom yeah go
ahead go ahead and go
while you're going you're looking for
stuff don't make my camera go dark okay
i won't because i won't make it go for
it
so
the [ __ ] the um the ashley angle went
on for a while that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
hilarious i was getting
kind of [ __ ] discombobulated i was
[ __ ] drinking my ass off
and um
okay where is it
see the thing is i got a new tablet and
i put my sim card in the new tablet my
new tab was little
and um
the little tablet
[ __ ]
i'm trying to see
the little tab that has all my
photographs in it
i sent a picture to keith
or uh
his name on well we're taking pictures
of the pictures
then i sent keith the [ __ ] i'm sorry
i've been uh i've been drinking so i'm
getting kind of [ __ ] um
out of order here at a bit
okay
okay
you guys are gonna [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
pissed me off
yeah i found it and then i found it and
i pressed the button and it went to the
bottom of the page oh my goodness you're
in all kinds of problems yeah i know
what it what
yeah so that's ashley all right so
ashley was super passable
it took me a while to realize that that
was trans female
i mean are they drinking though i mean i
probably wouldn't have thought yeah i
didn't i didn't well i don't like i said
i don't think about it i i i realized
you know i didn't definitely think about
it until you said something about i was
like yeah i was like whatever yeah it's
like she's trans look like a girl to me
yeah i don't i wasn't thinking about it
like i said
i don't know like i don't think about
that kind of [ __ ] that that's
maybe that's you i don't know that's
what i don't think about well you know
it's kind of i'm just kind of like hey
it's a person it's not really i'm not
[ __ ] that person so it's like why she
was trying to hit man she was trying to
[ __ ] hit him yeah clearly we'll let
you try to get [ __ ] tom is like super
super [ __ ] up yeah i mean
and she was kind of well yeah you know
what i mean i know but it's like she
because she's like i'm bisexual that's
what she said all right fair enough
she's like but it's like yeah she kept
coming up and she was talking to me like
i said mostly she was trying to get me
involved in witchcraft right and she was
trying to get you so she said well
that's here she said your boobs are
gorgeous she's like oh you know she was
jealous of your boobs okay yeah but yeah
so there was that whole thing yeah so
then like i said i was sober now i was
dancing my ass off i had a good time you
know the music was pretty good and stuff
like that later on like tom is
completely [ __ ] up you're right more
[ __ ] up than i've seen in a while yeah
so he goes up to pe to cash out right
and he didn't even know what the [ __ ]
was going on so i kind of had to like
tell the bartender he forgot he did it i
didn't tell him the next day no it was
fine i told you yeah that you gave him
like whatever tip or whatever and he
says to me
he's like that ashley girl was sucking
my dick and i was just like what she was
trying to
he's like
in the bathroom i was like okay whatever
so so then we leave she can reach down i
was like no no no no no
getting on her knees come come on come
on
i was just like okay
what the [ __ ] went in there i don't know
like i said i was dancing
i was weak man [ __ ] i couldn't fight
it off and i was trying to be polite you
know i mean [ __ ] she was cool though
she's cool just you know yeah she was
she was a little bit weird but she was
like you know i got a girlfriend i can't
do this she's i'm a [ __ ] her too
and i was like oh man she's getting sad
she knew you were vulnerable she was
taking advantage yeah you know what she
said she said
she said you're not trying to tell me i
got to go through proper channels and it
says yeah you got to go through proper
channels and she's like i'm going to
talk to her
that she was [ __ ] funny man
think about how funny that is
that's just [ __ ] funny don't tell me
i have to go through that that's like
some regular [ __ ] that happens
yeah yes
i mean pretty much every saturday you go
some [ __ ] like that's gonna happen yeah
don't tell me i haven't it's just like
some [ __ ] like that's gonna happen or dr
michael is gonna like lick your nipples
or something it's just it's gonna be
something like that
everyone tells me i gotta go through
proper channels as yeah she's okay i'm
gonna talk to her yeah she never did
that no okay she was [ __ ] i don't
think she talked to me after that she
was [ __ ] with me no it's because
that's because [ __ ] scott grabbed her
oh and drug her out of there oh okay
because he was getting jealous
uh
because she was gonna [ __ ] i wasn't
really watching what was going on she
was gonna split with us i wasn't really
watching what was going on because like
i said he was playing some good [ __ ] so
i was just kind of like yeah i was just
dancing whatever
and so i was like whatever and then like
i just thought it was funny that like
you were checking out and you were like
really really hammering yourself i was
[ __ ] she was trying to suck my dick
and she said i was just kind of like
yeah all right and then
and i told you it says she's trying to
[ __ ] you
oh well i got that yeah yeah yeah she
said she loves you that was she loves
you that was pretty awesome yeah she was
talking about your boobs and she was all
i mean even when she was like talking to
me she was like we're gonna do like some
wiccan spells and i'm just like yeah
yeah yeah like i said i was sober so i
was just kind of like awesome whatever
she was like her boobs are great
so it was it was that kind of situation
and then like so we leave and tom is
just like like i said he's like super
drunk he kept telling me well he kept
telling me how much ashley loved me like
he told me like 20 times yes and he kept
like yelling it in my face and like i
was like dude i know you you already
when i get drunk i'll repeat myself yeah
i think that i said it i know i was like
i was like you know you already told me
that right i was [ __ ] loaded and he
was like yelling it's like ah then i was
like okay cool yeah so we leave the club
and sophie our friends god if i checked
out or not told i watched you yeah i was
like like i said i called him later
i called my bartender
and i said dude did i pay you
i told you you did i was standing right
there yeah
did i tip you and he's like yeah i
watched you yeah i watched it i didn't
even remember i even said i was like hey
do you need my glasses and you're like
nah
i didn't even remember paying this was
the next morning i didn't even remember
paying
i don't remember and you didn't remember
either because i because sophie was like
please don't let him drive and i'm like
yeah i'm not going to but then he's like
no i'm going to drive and i was just
like oh [ __ ] we're going to die so he
gets in the car and he backs into
another car like like i said the car was
fine like our car wasn't [ __ ] up their
car was [ __ ] up yeah not hard i just
yeah he just kind of went and i was like
dude you just backed in another car i
was like [ __ ] that dude back there i
didn't see it and i was like yeah no
[ __ ] you didn't see it
and then like he drives out of the
parking lot and like goes like a block
and then i was like
pull over right yeah pull everywhere it
was it was it was normally i can drive
well i made you sit in the car for a
little while yeah but normally i can
drive this was an exceptional moment she
was like
i was like yeah no well i didn't really
want to drive because i was like man i
got to take my shoes off and all this
stuff like i said i was sober but i you
know i was like i can't drive in these
[ __ ] boots so i had we had to pull
over the parking lot i take my shoes off
and i drive in my bare feet and the
whole time i think i said this before
but you were because i was like i don't
remember how to get home exactly because
it's like all these toll roads
and so he has my phone
because he doesn't have a phone so i
have my phone and he had my gps on and
he kept like reading it out to me like
yeah it's 5.4 miles i'm like okay thank
you i get it 5.3 miles i'm like okay i
get it i get it like he just kept like
saying every navigation every point
however
he kept selling see now she's [ __ ]
i'm like she'll tell me when it's time
to turn i was like please just calm down
i was having a good time as a passenger
though i didn't have to drive i was
sitting there i've got [ __ ] i'm
navigating i was like [ __ ] sulu
it's like silly on the [ __ ] star trek
enterprise and then you get home we get
home okay
and i fall asleep
and then the next thing i know
i'm waking up go ahead and tell what
happened
jenny tells it the best because
she saw from her point of view i wasn't
aware of it and like i said i apologize
because some of you may have already
heard this story right because i think
we told it a couple times before but
yeah uh on some of the other ones but
this is like the side tracks so yeah in
case you weren't here and you didn't
hear it yeah this is great so he wakes
up we he you've seriously you'd only
been asleep for like an hour because we
didn't get home until maybe like 2 30.
because we stopped at uh circle k yeah i
got some [ __ ] i got a [ __ ] mcribs
microwave sandwich you got a burrito oh
yeah i [ __ ] toasted that [ __ ] up
[ __ ] microwaved it i had [ __ ]
barbecue sauce on it man when it was
done it was i didn't put pickles on it i
had some pickles down there it was like
right from [ __ ] it was better than
mcdonald's and this [ __ ] came out of a
place better than mcdonald's it was
better than me
hit that [ __ ] again man
i'm gonna hit that [ __ ] again yeah we
don't we don't have mcdonald's on the
way home from the club anymore no now we
just have to stop at circus okay and
like pick through whatever they're
[ __ ] yeah they're eating up all the
food by the time we get there well
because i mean to be fair to them it's
like two or three o'clock in the morning
and i'm sure everybody's probably like
eating the [ __ ] by now but it's like you
know every now and then they'll have
like a cuban sandwich or some [ __ ] left
over and i'll eat that but you know what
i mean
so
he said he goes in and gets sandwiches
we come home like i said i'm stone cold
sober
so we come home
and it was like three o'clock we ate the
sandwiches we go to sleep and then maybe
and i think it was an hour an hour and a
half later because i think it was about
4 30 ish so we'd only been asleep for
like an hour and a half and i wake up i
didn't hear anything i just i think it
was like some kind of spidey sense
and i wake up and i turn over because i
was kind of like facing the opposite
side of the of the room and i turn over
and i see tom standing at the end of the
bed
like facing the little bench that's at
the end of the bed and he was just
standing there and it was really creepy
yeah stand at the edge of the bed i was
like like i said this is like some like
the chick from paranormal activity it
was like that so he was just like
standing there and i just like i'm like
what are you doing and he says pissing
i'm pissing
and i was like
are you for real like peeing on the
floor are you peeing on the floor i said
i was like really upset i thought he was
peeing on the floor or like on the bench
yeah which is covered with like uh yeah
which is covered with like this velvety
kind of yeah yeah it's like a it's not a
[ __ ] what do you got it's like a little
box that you could that you can sit on
you can sit on it but you can open it up
and yeah yeah you can put stuff in there
standing right there and [ __ ]
dick in my hand should we do it it's
dark in there and i said i'm pissing but
i didn't remember that
yeah that's what you said i said i'm
pissing yeah just like that yeah and i
was like are you peeing on the floor
yeah and when she said that i woke up
because i didn't know it was dark i
couldn't see what you were doing what
the [ __ ] am i doing here
i was like yeah that's what i was just
wondering and i was like
man i must have pissed on the [ __ ]
floor this and that and i'm [ __ ]
reaching out and i pulled that thing out
i pulled it out of the [ __ ] room
yeah and i was reaching down [ __ ]
trying to touch and see where i had
passed i never could find it
and then i went to the bathroom and then
got in bed i said if i pissed then i'll
[ __ ] clean it up tomorrow
and then when i woke up there wasn't any
piss i was dreaming yeah you were there
i was dreaming and sleepwalking
that i was pissed which i've never seen
you do that before you see i thought i
was pissing in the uh
uh in the bathroom i thought i was in
the bathroom
yeah and i was dreaming that i was in
the bathroom pissing
i was interested though
i couldn't i couldn't piss
yeah i couldn't piss i was rocked up
[Laughter]
but no it was just your dick was smarter
than you were yeah well there's like a
safety mechanism it's a safety mechanism
yeah
but no i couldn't it was weird man i
thought i was it was very weird i
thought i was in the bathroom but i
wasn't understanding there's no telling
how long i was standing there i think i
was standing there a long time you might
have been because i kind of vaguely
remember little dreams and [ __ ]
happening and dreams and then me in the
bathroom taking a leak because i had had
to leave had to take a leak
but no i never did piss i was just
standing there
it's weird
michael schaefer i've been that drunk
before too tom i mean i think we all
have i've been i've been drunk enough
that i did sleep walking that i didn't
remember anything or well i don't think
i've ever been drunk enough that i
didn't remember anything from the night
before but i've been drunk enough that i
remembered like probably very little of
what happened the night before i've
never slept walked though yeah i was
drunk asleep never had that happen
because normally what will happen like i
said if you know if i have to go to the
bathroom in the light usually i'll start
dreaming that i'm going to the bathroom
but the bathroom that i find in my dream
is always like too gross to use so
that's my like my brain like waking me
up that's how that happens so usually
i'll be like oh [ __ ] i gotta get up you
know what i mean yeah oh they're seeing
too much testosterone in me [ __ ]
looking at the [ __ ] [ __ ] and
trying this yeah it's [ __ ] funny man
there is some weird [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] i've heard that that is a weird
thing i've been hearing from other
[ __ ] guys that tom's having all kind
of is that all of a sudden all of a
sudden all of a sudden men look like
women to you because you [ __ ]
when they stand next to you they're
nowhere near man as you well the thing
about it though is that like i said
ashley you couldn't tell that was a dude
like i said well i didn't it didn't
occur to me i'm gonna say dude people
get offended but it's in the currency
she didn't look like she was trans that
it didn't occur to me that's almost
trans like well like i said that it i
don't think about that kind of stuff
like you introduce me to somebody i'm
just kind of like okay you're you i
don't really like yeah
i i'm not i don't really get hung up
about
what you know who like what what's going
on with this person i'm just kind of
like okay well you are what you appear
to be that's fine yeah so i don't really
says in all her photos she hides her at
no she didn't have adam's apple
and so they're saying like well she was
that easy she must have had she must
have been carrying diseases or something
no what it was
i got the lowdown on it later from scott
see that's what i was asking because you
didn't tell me all this [ __ ] like at the
at the club she's married to a
girl and they got a kid together
yeah
and they're breaking up
basically
and [ __ ] you know i mean that that
was kind of the deal so
ashley's trying to [ __ ] start a new
life if that's what you want to put but
she's been
married and hemmed up for a while so
[ __ ] scott got her off of [ __ ]
some dating site
and uh
trying to make some money yeah can't
begrudge people trying to make that yeah
she's probably trying to she's trying to
make some money too that's what i'm
doing because it's gotta pay gratuity
and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know well he's got
money yeah he's got money he's got money
scott owns a [ __ ] uh bar down here
drives around a jaguar and [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm helping him out with hrt and stuff
hooked him up with the right people yeah
he came over yeah so he's on hrt trying
to lose a bunch of weight because he
plays tennis and [ __ ]
and he's got a girlfriend but his uh
that lives with him i mean they're
married aren't they well they're engaged
for sure i don't know if they got
married yet but they're definitely
engaged but her name's sam yeah but it
it he he brings her out sometimes yeah
but she doesn't go out anymore and
they're in an open relationship he's not
going anywhere as long as
she doesn't really she doesn't care she
doesn't care what he does as long as he
comes back
and he pays bills and [ __ ] you know
he does this [ __ ] part she doesn't
care what he does
there's a lot of that in this club
you know there's a lot of it especially
with the older people not the younger
people i mean everyone's just kind of
like whatever man whatever
whatever
that is permanent in that [ __ ] anyway
they're just uh they're having fun and
they don't take anything [ __ ]
seriously this is florida okay well and
i don't even know if that's um
exclusive to the gossip
i kind of feel like that's well i kind
of feel like that goth people are people
in there are more open
about it but i kind of feel like that
happens everywhere just like people
don't talk about it in florida florida's
[ __ ] got really good vibes but it's
insane it's insane people are [ __ ]
funny as [ __ ] here uh well the craziest
people from the rest of the country
floor-to-man inevitably yeah they're
fine there's no there is some truth to
that there's no real there's rules but
they're not the traditional rules it's
just kind of
okay man yeah oh yeah all right it's
just like it's hard for us to say
because it's just kind of like i don't
really know all these people so it's
hard to judge that's what i'm saying
it's like i've known all these people
like for years and years
so it's just kind of like whatever
they're doing like are they hurting
anybody they're not getting something
like okay whatever
like scott if that's what you want to do
yeah scott's straight as an arrow he
shows up with a [ __ ] transsexual girl
and no one liked playing with that i was
like all right fine yeah whatever okay
yeah she's cool yeah
whatever
yeah everybody well like i said
everybody cares most of the people that
go to barbarella
or which used to be our bar on saturday
night it tends to be an older crowd so
it's usually people i mean it's usually
people that lived through the 80s to
whatever degree so it's usually people
that are in their 40s or 50s they've
seen it but are still in the scene so
it's just kind of like those people have
been around forever so it's like you
can't really shock them with anything
anymore you could show up with this and
that they're just kind of like yeah okay
yeah and we run into like and young
people show up in their 20s and they're
kind of amazed by a lot of the [ __ ]
that's happening they go oh people do
this
yeah i keep talking about well that's
well see that's what you have to that
would be like i mean it's not it's not
equivalent because our parents weren't
no they were into like gotcha yeah but
it's jet x
yeah so the thing about it is that i you
know i don't know if there's any
equivalent because you know we know
people that are our age that have kids
that are in their 20s
and the kids that are in the 20 so it's
kind of like i kind of feel like people
that are in their 20s are always kind of
like grossed out by oh my god i don't
want to hear about like my parents doing
all this kind of stuff so there is that
but
honestly i feel like it's less i don't
know it's less of a thing because like i
said a lot of our friends that have kids
that age and they'll the kids will come
out to the club like with their
significant other whoever it happens to
be at the time and there's all kind of
and they're just kind of like yep
there's yeah they're 21 now and it's
like
and it's funny because we
it's not
they're not making any kind of statement
or anything they're just being who they
are they're not really even wearing it
on their sleeve they're just okay like
there's a couple we've known for [ __ ]
no man probably 11 12 13 years now
and she's a lawyer
okay
they got a lot of money she's a lawyer
he's the next con
they're in the fetish scene they always
have a girlfriend
that lives with them
i mean they have different but they
trade girlfriends out the girlfriend but
it's usually kind of like they'll have
one for like a long time a long time and
then that one will leave and then
they'll get it i'll get another
girlfriend so it's like a long-term
situation but it's and the girlfriend
lives in the house
yeah but they got kids so teenage
daughters and [ __ ] here in the house
knowing that all this is going on the
daughter's probably in her twenties
she's not she's gotta be gone because
she was a teenager back in those days
last time i was out right now and what's
funny is that they grow up seeing this
and they roll their eyes at it they're
just like oh my god they think it's
[ __ ] they think it's well like i said
they think it's ridiculous when it's
your parents it's embarrassing yeah i
get it yeah well i kind of feel like
that's a universal among like teenagers
there's like nobody wants to think about
their parents right having a third and
like strapping her to some [ __ ] in the
garage and whipping her nobody wants to
think about it
fetish stuff right nobody wants to think
about that and it does happen but nobody
wants to think about it and the daughter
is just like yuppy as hell when you're
older you're kind of like yeah i get it
but when you're like in your teens or
twenties you're like gross yeah they're
old yeah yeah i get it yeah the daughter
was like and the daughter and the friend
the daughter's friends would be over and
then we're throwing a party with we have
a party going on in there and [ __ ]
i'm cooking pizza remember that that's
right yeah you took all this
that was think it was my birthday yes
for the craziest pizza and i was like
get out of here
can you have a pizza that
has just oil on it and herbs no
cheese so they wanted like focaccia
yeah and then i want a tomato and they
were telling me let me go get out of
here i just kicked her out
and she wanted something on there that
was just totally ridiculous so like
don't [ __ ] with it i kind of remember
like you know i want some chocolate on
it or something some [ __ ] dipping [ __ ]
like that i was like no he stopped
[ __ ]
busting my nuts it wasn't chocolate it
was something crazy
crazy on it and i was like you're
[ __ ] with me get out of here
and uh it wasn't chocolate though but
the the [ __ ]
the daughters the daughter and her
friends were like like preppies
totally opposite
so remind me of remember the absolutely
fabulous program remember where the
[ __ ] [ __ ] mom had the real
conservative it's exactly like it was
exactly pretty much exactly
not in all situations because we do know
um some couples that have like
kids that are in their teens and
twenties that come out to the club now
that are also like into the same [ __ ]
but
sometimes it takes a while to get there
though because we do know this one
couple and they had a kid and um
well you know she has actually two kids
and the one older daughter is in her 20s
and then the one is like 18 19 something
like that and she went through a phase
where she was like oh man this goth [ __ ]
you guys are too old to be doing this
blah blah but then like a few years went
by and she matured a little bit and
she's like oh wait this shit's pretty
cool so now she brings her boyfriend to
the club too yeah but the couple was a
trip because
they're awesome they still come out we
saw we saw them they're friends we saw
them last week actually the the woman
is probably about five eight five five
seven maybe
she looks kind of like a lawyer or a
school teacher boobs and [ __ ] [ __ ]
showing up in
black rubber
the dude
looks like a miniature bonito mussolini
ball looks just like mussolini
i call what's up mussolini yeah that's a
bonito and he's like man
looks like a little
mussolini
and the girlfriends have ranged from
[ __ ] super hot
to to pretty good pretty good looking
and um
they're almost always younger but
honestly that's it's almost all and it's
her it's her doing it not yeah not him
yeah she gets girlfriends and he's like
we're gonna get you the nails
yeah it's a thrall it's always a thrall
they always have somebody but like i
said they tend to keep one for a very
long time now some now it's kind of like
a weird relationship where they got mad
one time
she was they were fighting
and i said uh where where are they and
she says i don't know [ __ ] them you know
what i mean then she storms across the
[ __ ] street remember from mannequins
yeah i was walking all sideways that was
just like trump that was a couple months
[ __ ] funny she was outside smoking
like with some other people [ __ ] i
don't know i don't know what i'm
bitching i was like oh [ __ ] yeah she was
bad she's mad at him something had
happened i don't know what happened but
yeah yeah she got mad for whatever
reason
and she knows she went stomping off
across the street you know i was like
getting those specials and [ __ ]
she
she stayed upright so yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] funny respect matt respect
i don't think we saw her again after
that so they appreciate it probably
kicked her out well like i said it's
kicked out yeah i mean they have a nice
house i don't know if they live in the
same one yeah they have a lot of time
ago yeah big two stones
so
but they always like move
the girlfriend in yeah because they have
like a bunch of feather stuff in their
house yeah like in the garage and stuff
their house was kind of like the house
we left but two stories like this one
nice nicer than this one actually from
what i remember that surprise it was
really that house was nice we had a
couple parties there they threw a
birthday party for me there
was several years ago i don't remember
if that was the same no because they had
a birthday party for me and then like
they had another party
that was for something else and then
they asked you to make pizzas there so
you brought all the stuff in a cooler
and you made pizza and he was like man
when you break pizza you really do make
it i thought you were [ __ ] and this
is no
he brought him we had this big huge
cooler and he brought like all the
ingredients and he brought the stone and
the peel and he brought real buffalo
mozzarella cheese and everything [ __ ]
and we made like a [ __ ] ton of fish
something for everybody no i don't i
don't really remember what he does for
living i don't know if he does anything
i think he does but i can't remember
right yeah to be honest she represented
him in some kind of child it's
they've been married they've been
married forever yeah that's how they got
married that's how he met her they've
been married forever but he did a little
bit of time
over something
i don't even know what it was i didn't i
don't even know either
i thought that i knew at some point but
yeah it seemed like it seemed like
something that wasn't really yeah
it was probably having to do a fetish
scene
maybe probably yeah maybe it was kind of
like an indecent exposure something like
that
you're not going to complain against it
or something that's what i mean but
she's like okay
she's like hell yeah all right
[Laughter]
but i mean they're [ __ ] serious any
fetish event they're [ __ ] funny
they're always there but they're super
nice i really i really like the two of
them i really like it i used to go to
lunch with them they're already every
freaking week or maybe
i think there are eight i think that
yeah i think they're about our age
you know late 40s early 50s same as us
but like i said you would be shocked um
at how uh because somebody said murder
hornet said i have a ex-girlfriend 10
years older than me she still goes out
clubbing like she's still in her 20s a
lot of people do and honestly
i don't know i kind of feel like maybe
some people still look at scants at that
but i'm like you would actually be
shocked at like how many people our age
or older
are still going out to clubs and it's
not kind of like oh you're out there
[ __ ] they're not all like [ __ ]
drinking toxins like passing out in the
gut or anything like that they're just
going out and having a couple drinks and
dancing like having a good time which
like i said i don't think there's
anything wrong with that grab this is
going about on about again about having
strangers cornhole
[Laughter]
look those scenes there are no strangers
those people all know each other they
all know it that's what i mean i think
it would be weird just like going
someplace and it's like hey some random
[ __ ] you don't know like that
seems like a recipe for disaster yeah
i kind of feel like if you're gonna do
that it's probably better to like
establish an actual like hopefully
they're friends of yours yeah like you
actually know those people yeah like
outside of doing that kind of yeah
according to them jenny and i don't go
to those kind of finished events we'll
go to the [ __ ] what's called a fetish
event at the dad's club which is nothing
more than fetish fashion no fetish
pretty much
and they'll do like some kind of like oh
we're gonna put somebody up on the thing
and whip them and everybody will look at
it and stuff like that but it's like
it's not an actual fetish event where
people are actually doing fetish yeah
which sometimes the castle has those
yeah the actual fetish events happen at
the castle and because they have they
have a dungeon yeah and those uh really
nothing really happens at those either
uh but those people know each other yeah
the [ __ ] where it goes down is that
private parties and that happens at
[ __ ] mansions okay that doesn't
happen in the [ __ ] hood that's in the
[ __ ] matches
and um
it's my invitation only that's my eyes
wide shut stuff exactly like that but
it's just well they all know each other
that's the thing it's just like anything
else it's not really like i kind of feel
like maybe people perceive that it's
like oh there's some weird freaky [ __ ]
like you're just going like banging a
bunch of people you've never seen before
no that's not usually what happens like
i said usually it's like well much like
the goth scene the fetish scene is very
close-knit
um everybody knows everybody or knows
somebody that knows that other person so
it's like this isn't like just some
random person you know who that person
is it's at one of these multi-million
dollar
miami tampa or orlando mansions that
have pools
they have catering and then they'll have
a [ __ ] dj
and yeah sex is happening but those
people all know each other they've been
going to those same groups of parties
for [ __ ] decades that's what i mean
so it's not like you're just like
showing up being like hey who are these
people let's [ __ ] these people it's nice
these are [ __ ]
hot people that have been in it for a
long time
and judges
and [ __ ] state representatives and
[ __ ] prosecutors and [ __ ] these are
powerful people just like eyes wise [ __ ]
you knew who knew all about that is
[ __ ] um
dimitri
dimitri was all into that scene he
[ __ ] uh spun at some of those seeds
i mean i went to a few of those kind of
parties back in the day before i met you
yeah he says it's not he said he said
that was a lot of that was back in the
day it's not as common as it was it's
not yeah it was more like 90s late 90s
early 2000s yeah the ones i went to were
mid 90s i want to say it was like mid
90s and it was like miami or miami fort
lauderdale that kind of area they used
to have like a lot of them but he said
jen wasn't in on it it was just before
he met jen
yeah but he was spinning at some of
those
yeah
well like i said it's not
and what do you think yeah when you
think about it it's not really all that
weird it's like a big event big event if
that's what you're into and you know the
other people that are into it it's not
really all that sono it's it's in an
enclosed community on a little private
[ __ ] estate
all lit up [ __ ] trees and pool and
pool party and
a bunch of nudism happening and half
nude people or just nude people walking
around and [ __ ]
[ __ ] having sex and [ __ ] doing
fetish stuff and swapping wives but they
know each other
yeah they're not they're not
yeah it's not just like random it's not
random then they don't just like let
randos in there either no i kind of feel
like that's what happened because like i
said if you go to mannequin because
mannequins will have like a fetish event
like a fetish party like every now and
then there they just had another one
they had one like last friday i think
but like i said that's mostly like a
just a fashion thing
um you know but when you have like an
actual fetish party yeah like a serious
one yeah they will kind of vet like it
comes in there yeah the other thing is
there's a lot of rules
yeah there's not a free form they have
dress codes and they have like all these
like really strict rules because they
don't like i said they just don't want
some random [ __ ] coming in there
and like they mostly know each other but
there's a bunch of bunch of special
etiquette that they use
you can't just go up and [ __ ] demand
something out of people they're like
[ __ ] you yes it's they all you got to be
in with them
you know what i mean and uh they're all
that some people are into certain things
other people aren't but you know when
according to what dimitri said he said
most of it is just [ __ ] soft bondage
and role playing it's nothing that's
what i mean i kind of feel like you
don't really see the real extreme [ __ ]
like i said i went to a party um i think
it was in fort lauderdale i want to say
it was fort lauderdale it was probably
back in the 90s
and there were some people there that
were into
um
scat play
damn not
uh not my favorite thing yeah
he said this but
they weren't doing it live but they did
have like an area for that right and i
was just kind of like yeah not going to
meet yourself no thank you dimitri told
me that the uh the the events that he
was talking about that were [ __ ]
going on in those mansions was very
vanilla
very vanilla i imagined it was
the thing about yeah like i mean people
talk about fetish like ooh it's his big
thing but it's like most people it's
like ah they just wanted to get like
[ __ ] handcuffed and like whipped and
[ __ ] like that yeah really that's like
nothing dominatrix there that's like
some fifty shades of grey [ __ ] right
dominators there and [ __ ] you know
dominator masters and [ __ ] with all
their equipment and they're like [ __ ]
real good at the train yeah eat out of a
dog whatever they had all this stuff
well it was mostly i think was [ __ ] like
uh suspension and
crap like that you know i mean which i
don't know i'm not into that i don't
really don't care but he said most of it
was um
the food and the [ __ ] uh just the
socialization and sure people may in
role play and people making out [ __ ]
freaking you know
and uh
he said that
he said that there was money involved in
some of it because you have powerful
rich guys and they [ __ ] look like
[ __ ] and they want to uh do some role
play with somebody's wife who's [ __ ]
hot as hell and they're not really all
that
wealthy so he makes a donation and the
girl is a performer so she you know puts
on a show for the dude or does the thing
for the dude
and uh do you think the husband's there
you know what i mean as an assistant and
[ __ ] sometimes so
there's some of that i wouldn't wouldn't
necessarily call it prostitution because
there really wouldn't be any sex
involved
it's just uh fetish type [ __ ]
bondage
bondage and role play stuff
yeah and like i said it's like if that's
what people and most of that stuff like
you said is very very vanilla yeah most
of those most of them are not into
actual
intercourse yeah it's usually like other
[ __ ] it's all the stuff yeah
other [ __ ] like i'm not saying they
don't do that but i'm just saying yeah
most of it's not most of it's like all
the like accoutrements like kind of
around well if [ __ ] a lot of the
fetish scene um [ __ ] the
the the whole idea that there's this hot
chick who's the dominatrix you can't get
it is the whole erotic thing for the
dude
you know what i mean it's it's like an
unattainable woman who's gonna [ __ ]
do all this [ __ ] yeah because some dudes
are super yeah and they'll pay because
they can't get it because they can't get
it they can't get it yeah and then it's
like ooh now i'm gonna pay her extra to
like step up yeah she's gonna kick me in
the nuts
or you know which like i said i could i
could i could get behind she's gonna
spit in my mouth and call me a piece of
card
like it's a reward make me drink out of
the toilet yeah
maybe yeah they do well you've never
seen them like making them drink out of
a dog bowl or on the toilet or something
like that yeah in [ __ ] videos and
stuff every now and then i've heard
about it i don't think that's what
happened to those parties well maybe not
at the parties but i have seen it
otherwise i have seen that well some
guys like to be degraded like that's
what and honestly like i kind of feel
like and i'm sure this isn't a universal
role but i do kind of feel like a lot of
those dudes that are really into being
degraded like either powerful dudes yeah
it's usually well because in their life
they have to like control all this stuff
and they have to feel like they're
always on all the time so it's like in
their sexual life they want to be like
just a piece of [ __ ]
so they like they enjoy being treated
like a piece of [ __ ] they want to drink
out of the toilet they want some chicken
high heels to like step on their knots
or whatever and i that's very very
interesting to me that's very
interesting to me but you know
well
i've seen it they ask the dude first
everything that they do they [ __ ]
well that's another thing too you can't
just do whatever the [ __ ] you want you
have to there's all those dudes looking
for certain things in some ways it's
like a lot more to navigate than just
regular vanilla
because you have to have like all these
parameters it's like you know what are
what are the extent of like what we can
do what's the safe word like if we if i
go too far
you know how to how do you get me to
stop and [ __ ] like that so they really
have to like have a lot of discussion
and in some ways that's why i would
argue like why the fetish scene is maybe
more
maybe more psychologically healthy than
like regular sexy because at least they
actually have a discussion about this is
what we want to do like this is too much
this is you know what i mean and they
is this okay is this not okay um they
really do like
communicate like pretty well on that
kind of stuff generally
and that's like i said that's why you
can't just like wander into the [ __ ]
because there's like a whole bunch of
like rules about it danny rowling said
what actual year did chicks start
shaving their bushes on a mass scale
that was probably 90s i feel like it was
probably the 1990s i feel like it was
probably the 90s i kind of feel like the
last heyday of like the the full bush
was maybe
70s was the was the big heyday everybody
liked that because it was natural
sadie's 70s was out of [ __ ] control
but
um yeah i kind of feel like in the 80s
people started safe well especially
after they were wearing that like
[ __ ] aerobic gear that came like way
the [ __ ] up here on your thighs so it's
like you kind of had to shave at least
some or like some hair would poke out
with the you go back into the center
when you go back and look at 70s porn
very few of those women were shaved and
the ones that were shaved were kind of
like the fetishy ones
i can't name them offhand but there was
a blonde that was always [ __ ] shaved
big boobs but i can't remember what her
name was and that was the first time i
saw in the 70s she was like proto goth
it's really weird to think about because
i kind of feel like in the 70s and it's
not like i was you know watching a bunch
of porn or nothing like because i was a
kid in the 70s but i'm just saying that
it feels like couldn't watch it in the
70s well no i was like i said i need a
little bit of an eight millimeter
[ __ ] that too yeah so you really kind
of had to go out of your way you're
right but i do kind of feel like you see
it now [ __ ] on in on the internet
yeah i do kind of feel like
you know people had big bushes in the
70s and that was kind of like fine
because like i said it was natural but
they didn't know any better i kind of
yeah i kind of feel like once the 80s
got started because everything was kind
of very it went to artificial well it
went to video and because porn went to
video and it was more readily accessible
i think women started being like oh [ __ ]
i need to like shave all that [ __ ] off
right
because of a lot of the outfits they
were wearing and stuff like yeah and it
was just uh
70s it was
i think 60s it was it went from illegal
to legal in the 70s
porn in the united states did it started
to become control but there wasn't
really an art to it yet they tried to
make the [ __ ]
to a movies really they were
doing full featured films
which that didn't sell well i mean what
sell well back then but that's not what
the essence of porn was the essence of
porn was actually what you saw later in
the in the 80s which was vhs and people
playing it at home on their [ __ ]
yeah these vcrs because [ __ ] the only
place you'd see porn was in a theater
and if you're in a theater [ __ ] full
of dudes [ __ ] jerking off and [ __ ]
yeah nobody wants this nobody wants to
go there you want to do that
[ __ ] these weird coin-operated
[ __ ] jerk-off booths and [ __ ] [ __ ]
nasty [ __ ] and that wasn't to so
quality control was [ __ ] bad
you know what i mean
because you
it's scuzzy dudes to begin with who are
[ __ ] renting this [ __ ] when the vhs
when the vcr came out
it's now going mainstream
so the entire industry has to become
tightened up a lot much more efficient
dropping all these pretenses about it
being a movie and having a story it's
just scenes
scene after scene after scene all on a
good vhs tape that you could buy or rent
and um that's that was the beginning of
modern porn really
and uh that was also the beginning of
[ __ ]
hygiene and professionalism
because when you started to see the
beginnings in the 80s the [ __ ]
professional porn superstars like ginger
lin and amber lynn they all had lynn on
their names and [ __ ] names but uh
because lynn is the morning
i wonder if that was because lynn was a
very very common middle name
i think from people uh uh for women of a
certain age i think ginger lin was a
star if you looked like her then you put
the name so it was kind of like bruce
lee where everybody everyone being bruce
lee you're right that's what i think it
is
so
and then uh you know life imitates art
when people are [ __ ] seeing the porn
and [ __ ] you have professional porn
stars with good [ __ ] hygiene and
grooming all of a sudden they expect
that from the women and it starts and it
starts [ __ ] becoming mainstream i
think yeah and i i definitely think it
was porn that started then
you know they were like starting to
raise the standard well dudes watch porn
and now dudes are expecting women they
sleep with to not have pubic hair so
everyone's but then it went to the men
yeah
then it went to the men because freaking
looking for him hey we gotta do we all
gotta do it yeah so you know
and
but
[ __ ] 91 when i joined the army
in the infantry we all went commando
which is you don't wear underwear
because [ __ ] in the field is light
infantry that's just something more to
[ __ ] chafe the [ __ ] out of you while
you're [ __ ] marching
and when you're in the field you can't
take a shower you just basically clean
yourself with [ __ ] handy wipes so you
start shaving
and it's just that's where the stance is
so going commando is no underwear and
shave so you're ready for [ __ ] porn
you get habits you get those did you
bleach your [ __ ] didn't bleach my
[ __ ] no reason
just wondering yeah
so
it's just the way it would evolve for us
you know i don't know why what they do
now they're trying to do [ __ ] look at
some of these young people they look
[ __ ] terrible a lot of them that i
see
bad physical shape and [ __ ] well i
haven't really watched any recent porn
so i don't know no i'm not talking about
recent porn the recent porn stars
actually look great i'm talking about
actual just people walking around
some of the newer generations it's just
like some of these dudes don't even look
like they went through puberty
they're just fat
fat little skinny arms
hairy as [ __ ]
but you know i just i don't know weird
they were just kind of like it's just
too much for me to deal with maybe too
much for me to deal with i'm not going
to get laid so i'm not even going to try
that it looks a lot of look like losers
or the uh the other extreme
kids 18 looks fantastic and i go [ __ ]
you're on [ __ ] steroids i see that
too
caitlyn higgins said do you think they
that dichotomy of bdsm is only
associated with power or lack thereof if
so if anyone who's into it really
mentally healthy i always thought it was
childish um i liked the i liked the
[ __ ] to be honest i was like in
fashion in some ways though
like i said i would kind of argue that
maybe it might be slightly more mentally
healthy than people that don't
well no because there's always power
dynamics i never cared in any
relationship i never over analyzed any
of that [ __ ] no what i'm saying there's
always power dynamics in any
relationship and i kind of feel like
bdsm at least is forthright about that
and have discussions about it and like
set the parameters of like what
everyone's role is so in that way i kind
of feel like they have their [ __ ]
together more than people that don't
really examine it in any way to me i
always thought it was unnecessarily over
complicated and kind of
kind of i don't know i want to say
[ __ ] ritualistic and maybe a little
bit childish but i always liked the
outfits i liked the way it looked the
clothes and [ __ ] the outfits i always
thought that was great
yeah i mean sometimes like when actual
sex is involved you're just kind of like
jesus christ you just want to get on
with it let's go yeah yeah like i get
that i get that like uh but you know
um glenn little says i talked my brother
into going into a swinger house in
australia 100 for free pool and beer and
sex never saw him so happy he never
thanked me oh well he's dead now is he
really
well i'm sorry about that unless you're
[ __ ] with me in which case whatever
no way you're telling crap there's no
tell you anything the worst job in the
world jizz moppered a porn video or yeah
yeah probably
good things those are all gone
yeah they're so gross we were just
watching that movie hardcore that they
filmed at actual like porn theaters in
l.a they were cheap as [ __ ] looking and
you know like [ __ ] tug parlors or
what the [ __ ] ever like back in l.a at
the time i'm like man those places are
so gross they never like washed anything
like everything like looks sticky
perverted
[Laughter]
michael schaefer said you take the
street you first lived on oh yeah i've
heard this and your first pet's name to
come up with your porn name i have a
shitty porn name my porn name would be
ridgewood colonel
that's not a good-born name it's jackson
kitty
that's actually a pretty good point
well kind of like jackson galaxy yeah
who actually is who is actually like
the cat daddy good tips
granthar's poor name is abraham kent
that's pretty good actually that's a
pretty good porn name mine is shitty
mine is shitty
packard
that's a good that's a good one
dick packard even though it kind of
sounds like um a dude that would have
worked at nasa back in the 50s
but it also sounds like a poor name
so that's why it's good because it's
like it could go either way uh people in
this booth would jizz on the buttons and
where you put the money for the next
sucker to touch that's what i mean
i kind of feel like it's not like the
people that worked there were all that
concerned about hygiene i would imagine
and it's like they probably just got
minimum wage and they're just kind of
like man i'm not mopping up after these
gross ass [ __ ]
like these [ __ ] old middle-aged
fat dudes that are like watered in there
and [ __ ] like that i kind of feel like
it's that
yikes
jenny i'm getting sleepy you hungry you
getting hungry yeah starving okay then
let me make us some d what are you gonna
make i don't know see what's down there
what i got
i got uh mexican
chicken yeah so i can do more tacos i
got uh
a poor tenderloin that i could slice and
make sandwiches like maybe out of
[ __ ] pita bread
with cheese or something what are you
interested in i don't know sandwich
sounds good sandwiches sounds good that
makes this sandwich little said he is
dead well i am sorry though okay i
didn't know if you were just [ __ ]
with me you never know because some some
people have like weird all right people
i'm gonna go ahead and [ __ ] shut this
[ __ ] down
that's another shirt that we needed so a
couple of people have requested that we
have yeah shut this [ __ ] down sure all
right
so we will be back on
sunday evening and we're going to be
talking about
the george romero film monkey shines
from the late 1980s that's the movie
yeah we're gonna be talking about that
movie man
yeah that's the one we're gonna be
talking about so hopefully you guys come
back and join us have a good weekend up
until then thank you for dropping by
thanks for hanging out with us thanks
for super chats and we will see you guys
again on sunday evening